Happy Es gibt hier in den Fritz Studios einen Zettel, da steht drauf, nicht trinken, nicht essen, nicht rauchen, keine Drogen, Mobiltelefone aus, Fenster nicht öffnen. Und es gibt Gerüchte, die ich an dieser Stelle weder bestätigen noch dementieren möchte, dass das unter anderem für die folgenden beiden Leute geschönen ist, nämlich Starbuck und Andreas Bog vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallo und guten Abend.
Ich bin unschuldig.
Das sagen sie alle. Wo seid ihr hier gelandet? Fragt euch jetzt vielleicht. Naja, 29. Juli ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat, das heißt im Blue Moon gibt es heute Chaos Radio. Und Chaos Radio heißt immer Chaos Computer Club. Ist ja klar, gehört da zusammen. Und da geht es heute um ein Thema, was ich einfach cool finde, weil es so was Geheim-Erkenntemäßiges hat. Es ist nämlich so, dass die NSA, das ist eine amerikanische Geheimorganisation, ich weiß nicht, ob der Vergleich mit dem BND wirklich zutreffend ist, aber vielleicht kann ihr euch da was von drunter vorstellen. Seit langem etwas arbeitet, was Tempest heißt, ein geheimes Forschungsprogramm, um zu gucken, wie man an elektronischen Geräten Informationen absaugen kann, ohne dass derjenige, der davor sitzt, es mitbekommt. Wenn man jetzt denkt, ach, ist doch total einfach, kann ich einfach irgendwie so abhören oder WLAN mitschneiden, haben die doch schon tausendmal erzählt. Falsch. Es geht heute um elektromagnetische Abstrahlung. Und was das genau ist, erkennt man jetzt entweder Starbuck oder Andreas.
Ich zeig auf Andreas.
Er zeigt auf Andreas. Andreas, was ist elektromagnetische Abstrahlung und warum machen wir das jetzt zwei Stunden lang?
Also, das stellen wir uns mal ganz dumm. Wir stellen uns einen Raum vor.
Warte, warte, warte.
Und in dem Raum, da ist ein elektrischer Leiter gespannt. Und durch diesen Leiter lassen wir Strom fließen. Und wer sich dunkel an seinen Physikunterricht erinnert, der weiß, so sich bewegende elektrische Teilchen, so Elektronen, wenn die ihren Fluss ändern, erzeugen die Magnetfelder. Also sich ändernde Magnetfelder, wenn sich der Fluss ändert. Und wenn die sich vor sich hin ändern, dann breiten sie sich auch im Raum aus als elektromagnetische Strahlung. Kennt man vom Radio, da wird es absichtlich gemacht. Das Problem ist das, Elektronik macht das immer und ständig. Also immer in dem Moment, wo sich Elektronen bewegen, in jedem elektronischen Gerät entsteht Abstrahlung. Ja, der eine oder andere kennt vielleicht das Stichwort Elektrosmog. Das geht so ein bisschen in die Richtung. Allerdings betrifft Elektrosmog auch gewünschte Abstrahlung. Es gibt aber auch unerwünschte Abstrahlung. Das ist eigentlich unser Thema heute. Also, in so einem elektronischen Gerät, das was da passiert, was auf dem Bildschirm dargestellt wird, was so ein Computer beispielsweise berechnet.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, können wir vielleicht zumindest am Anfang, später dann okay, aber zumindest am Anfang auf ein bestimmtes elektronisches Gerät beschränken?
Röhrenstrahlmonitoren.
Röhrenstrahlmonitoren sind ganz einfach. Das sind, ich glaube, die Hörer sind alle alt genug, um noch diese Monitore mit...
Na ja, man weiß es nicht.
Wie Fernseher früher waren, ja. So wie Fernseher früher waren, ein Kathodenstrahlmonitor. Und in so einem Kathodenstrahlmonitor wird ja das Bild aufgebaut von links nach rechts, von oben nach unten. Da wandert so ein Elektronenstrahl lang. Und wie hell der sein soll, das wird dadurch gesteuert, wie viele Elektronen auftreffen. Das wiederum wird dadurch gesteuert, wie viele, also wie groß die Spannung ist, mit der sie beschleunigt werden. Und das wiederum heißt, dass es da einen solchen Leiter gibt, wo mal mehr und mal weniger Elektronen durchfließen. Das wiederum bedeutet, es entsteht eine elektromagnetische Welle, die man messen kann. Also sind noch alle mitgekommen.
Darf ich es mal kurz auf meine Art und Weise zusammenfassen? Ein Kathodenstrahlmonitor ist ein Gerät, wo eine Fläche, die leuchten kann, mit was beschossen wird. Nämlich mit Strom quasi.
Genau, mit Elektronen.
Und Strom strahlt halt immer, also was irgendwie jeder sehen kann, der sein Handy zum Beispiel mal an seine Lautsprecherboxen hält. Oder ein nicht abgeschirmtes Gerät. Und das kann man irgendwie messen.
Genau.
Und irgendwie heißt in dem Fall, ich kann sozusagen diese Information, die eigentlich auf diese Glasscheibe auftritt und dann munte Bilderpunkte macht, kann ich auslesen und mir das auch irgendwo anders wieder dran tun.
Genau. Und dieses Messen macht man mit einem Gerät, das einem Radioempfänger nicht unehnlich ist. Denn elektromagnetische Wellen, wenn sie wieder auf einen Leiter treffen, induzieren einen Strom, der wiederum sich genauso verhält wie der Strom, der die magnetische Welle mal losgeschickt hat, die elektromagnetische Welle. Das setze ich mir am Radio auch die ganze Zeit ein.
Aber das hört sich jetzt so an, als ob ich jetzt jeder hingehen könnte und sein Radio nimmt und stellt das mal eben ins Nachbarzimmer und liest irgendwie ab.
Konnte man tatsächlich bei Kartonschallmonitoren so tun? Also man hat keinen Radio genommen, sondern einen Fernseher.
Man hat einen alten Fernseher genommen. Beim Fernsehempfang fühlt sich ja auch so, dass man da einen Empfänger hat und eine Frequenz. Und dann musste man bloß ein bisschen was umlöten und dann ging das.
Was genau musste man da umlöten?
Man hat keinen Demodulator mehr, sondern man braucht einen Integrator. Das heißt, man musste an der Stelle noch einen Kondensator reintun.
Um das vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen detaillierter zu machen, also die Monitore rasten ja mit einer gewissen Frequenz ab.
Also der Monitor besteht aus Pixel und diese Pixel werden dann in einer Art und Weise abgelaufen.
Genau, zu einer gewissen Zeit wird genau dieses eine Pixel angestellt. Das heißt, dann wird man auf der anderen Seite einen Fernseher hat, der genau in der gleichen Frequenz, also in dem gleichen Zeitintervall, jetzt irgendwie sein eigenes Pixel ansteuert, kann man den als Eingang, praktisch die Abstrahlung von dem Röhrenstrahlmonitor raufgeben und somit praktisch den Pixel hell machen, wenn er auch auf dem Röhrenstrahlmonitor hängt.
Also ich mache eigentlich nichts anderes, als dass ich dem ganz alten Fernseher, den ich habe, sage, pass mal auf, empfange mal jetzt bitte keinen Fernsehsignal, sondern empfange mal bitte einfach das, was der andere Monitor da abstrahlt.
Genau.
Aber das funktioniert heutzutage nicht mehr?
Heutzutage ist es ein bisschen anders, weil wir ja keine Röhrenmonitore mehr haben, sondern LCD-Monitore. Ja, und da ist das große Problem, dass da ja die Pixel nicht mehr einzeln angesteuert werden, sondern wird eine ganze Zeile auf einmal eingeschaltet.
Das heißt, normalerweise beim Röhrenstahlmonitor gehe ich irgendwie vom ersten Pixel oben links, zum letzten Pixel unten rechts. Oder wie auch immer, einzeln was fällt. Und jetzt sagen alle ersten Pixel, alle zweiten Pixel, alle dritten Pixel und so weiter.
Genau. Und das macht es komplizierter. Also man kann jetzt nicht hingehen und sich einen anderen LCD-Monitor nehmen und muss dann bloß einen Kondensator einlöten und ein bisschen Timing machen, sondern man muss dann schon relativ tief in die Trickkiste greifen. Das sind halt digitale Signale, das ist alles nicht mehr so einfach wie früher.
Nicht mehr so einfach wie früher. Jetzt haben wir vorhin gesagt, irgendwie okay, wir nehmen einen Fernseher, stellen ihn nebenan und schon ist der Möhren- der Möhren-Ronitor der Röhren-Monitor abgehört. Jetzt sagst du nicht so einfach. Heißt das, wir bewegen uns in einem technischen Feld, wo sowas wie die eingangs erwähnte NSA Zugriff haben oder kann sich das schon jeder zuhause basteln, wenn er nur will?
Ich denke, das ist lösbar mit Technik, die man sich heutzutage kaufen kann. Es ist nicht mehr so wie früher, dass man Millionen für Equipment ausgeben musste, sondern das notwendige Equipment ist eigentlich verfügbar, kostet relativ wenig Geld heutzutage.
Da kannst du ein Haus nochmal sagen.
Für 1000 Euro kann man sich das Equipment hinstellen, das geht. Dann muss man viel selber forschen und basteln. Wenn man eine Lösung will, die das fertig macht, es gibt so graue Kisten zu kaufen, Export beschränkt, wo dann einfach das fertige Signal rauskommt. Auch Serialleitungen, Tastaturen und so weiter sind natürlich nicht so billig. Wenn man selber gewillt ist zu basteln, kann man sich nicht für 1000 Euro schon das passende Funk-Messequipment kaufen.
Da stellt es mich natürlich die Frage, habt ihr das schon mal gemacht?
Na ja, nicht selber gebastelt, aber schon mal was abgehört. Was das Schöne daran ist, dass die Rechner heutzutage so schnell sind, dass man inzwischen alles in Software machen kann. Das heißt, man braucht halt nur noch ein kleines Frontend und praktisch die Antenne und irgendwie ein Device, was ausreichend viele Samples pro Zeit aufnimmt und alles andere. Also die ganze Auswertung und versuchen, aus den Signalen Buchstaben rauszuextraieren, das macht man heutzutage alles in Software im Computer. Da gibt es halt dieses tolle Gnu-Radio oder USRP, Universal Software...
Radio Peripheral.
Weißt du, was Tempest heißt?
Kannst du Tempest aussprechen?
Nein, Tempest ist tatsächlich keine Abkürzung.
Doch, ist doch wohl.
Nein, es ist nicht. Es wird immer behauptet, es sei eines.
Temporary Amination and Spurious Transmission. Sagt mir die Alwissende Müllhalde Wikipedia.
Die muss es ja wohl wissen.
Die hat aber nicht Recht, sondern es hat einfach diesen Codenamen bekommen.
Da ist sogar eine Quellenangabe dabei. Das ist ja nicht häufig so in der Wikipedia.
Nein, das heißt eigentlich nach einem Stück von Shakespeare. Die Interpretation der Abkürzung wurde hinterher festgelegt.
Das behauptest du doch jetzt bloß.
Ich habe Instagram-Kommissionen.
Okay, da haben wir jetzt den ersten Streitpunkt, zu dem ich das hier sagen möchte. Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 Ihr merkt schon, das ist ein weites Feld. Also elektromagnetische Abstrahlung, da muss man auch Bock drauf haben. Das kann man nicht einfach so machen. Aber wir wollen heute darüber reden, wie einfach es doch eigentlich ist, so verschiedene technische Geräte abzuhören. Einfach indem man sich daneben setzt und zuhört, was die so ausstrahlen. Wenn ihr da Fragen zu habt, dann könnt ihr gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Und keine Ahnung, vielleicht habt ihr ein bestimmtes Gerät, wo ihr wissen wollt, ob das geht oder vielleicht wollt ihr wissen, wie man nicht abgehört wird. Oder vielleicht wisst ihr, ob Tempest eine Abkürzung ist oder auch nicht. Oder ihr wisst, was Rechteckwellen sind und wolltet dazu mal was erzählen. Was auch immer ihr machen wollt, ruft einfach hier an 0331 70 97 110. Aber das muss ich auch gleich am Anfang dazu sagen, seid jetzt nicht böse, wenn wir euch nicht sofort reinnehmen, weil es gibt ja so einiges zu klären. Aber wie gesagt, anrufen, wir kümmern uns drum. So, wo haben wir stehen geblieben?
Tempest selber gemacht. Wir hatten auf dem Kongress, CCC veranstaltet ja einmal im Jahr ein Kongress, zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, 1998, damals noch im Haus am Kölnischen Park, jemanden, der das vorgeführt hat, und zwar genau die analoge Röhrenmonitorgeschichte, was wir eben beschrieben haben. Was auch interessanterweise die einzige Form von Tempest war, über die lange Zeit geredet wurde. Wahrscheinlich, weil es so einfach nachzubauen war. Mitte der 80er gab es die ersten Veröffentlichungen von einem gewissen Win-Fan-Egg. Weswegen Tempest auch unter dem Begriff Fan-Egg-Strahlung bekannt ist. Der redet halt über analoge Monitore.
Also was der damals gemacht hat, ist irgendwie durch London gelaufen, durch den Finanzdistrikt, und hat genau das getan, wovon wir jetzt hier reden, die Strahlung der Monitore, die da sind, mal auf der Straße aufgefangen und den Leuten dadurch klargemacht, was da überhaupt passiert. Die Geheimdienste haben das schon früher gemacht, seit den 50ern wahrscheinlich schon, seit die ersten Computer oder elektronischen Geräte aufgetaucht sind. Aber er war der Erste, der es mal wirklich publik gemacht hat und einen ziemlich großen Aufschrei damals hervorgerufen hat. Und alle Leute haben sich hinüber den Kopf zusammengeschlagen. Und wir müssen jetzt mal was dagegen tun, Abstrahlung, Abstürmen und so weiter.
Und ist da was dagegen getan worden?
Das kommt drauf an, wo man guckt. Also einen Ausflug, den ich ja sehr empfehlen kann, ist ins Stasi Museum in Lichtenberg. Da gibt es nämlich den Kupferkeller zu besichtigen. Das ist das Rechenzentrum der Stasi gewesen. Und das war, ich glaube, zwei Etagen je 100 oder 150 Quadratmeter komplett mit dicken Kupferplatten ausgekleidet. Also Decke, Fußboden, alle Wände, an den Türen Dichtungen, einmal komplett ringsum.
Und ohne Fenster wahrscheinlich.
Natürlich ohne Fenster. So, das ist der Kern eines Gebäudes gewesen, außenrum Büros, wie man sowas halt baut. Da kann man sich das mal angucken. Da sieht man auch, dass es irgendwie schon seit Jahrzehnten auch ernst genommen wurde. Das kann man machen. Nur arbeitet es sich immer so schlecht in Büros, die komplett in Kupfer ausgekleidet sind.
Das fühlt sich mir jetzt auch nur mäßig spannend vor.
Aber gut. Ja. Die Alternative sind speziell abstrahlgeschützte Systeme, die man aber natürlich auch nicht so einfach zu kaufen kriegt. Denn wenn man sie zu kaufen kriegt, dann sind sie teuer. Also bemerkenswerterweise ist das Problem in einer wenig bekannt. Also auch in der Industrie, Leute, die sich Gedanken, weil die sich das machen können, können das nicht.
Weil du erzählst mir gerade, das Geheimdienste geht ihr zumindest davon aus, irgendwie schon seit mehreren Jahrzehnten wissen, was da geht. Aber so draußen in der normalen Welt ist es eher egal.
So ist das, ja. Also die älteste Quelle, die ich gefunden habe, ist ein Declassified-Dokument aus den USA, aus dem Jahre 1943, wo also jemand festgestellt hat, dass bestimmte Kryptogeräte den Klartext mit auf die Leitung tun.
Ok, also Geräte sind dafür zuständig, etwas, was ich da reingebe, so zu verschlüsseln, dass es nur derjenige verstehen kann, der sozusagen das passende Gegenstück dazu hat. Und die haben quasi durch die Art und Weise, wie sie es verarbeitet haben...
Genau, also da kam hinten das verschlüsselte Signal raus. Aber wenn man genau hingeguckt hat, dann hat man halt auch noch so ein bisschen Abstrahlung gesehen. Das war jetzt nicht wirklich Tempest, weil es ja leitungsgebunden ist und nicht davon entfernt.
Wie das heißt, also Tempest heißt, also dieses Codewort für Abstrahlung heißt nur so, wenn es wirklich nicht...
Elektromagnetisch abgestrahlt ist. Aber was man natürlich hätte tun können, ist irgendwie halt auch das Kabel, wo es übertragen wird, sendet natürlich auch Wellen aus.
Theoretisch hätte man es wahrscheinlich auch gesehen. Also allgemein ist Tempest halt ein Teilbereich der sogenannten Seitenkanalangriffe. Das heißt, man hat einen physikalischen Vorgang, der eine Berechnung durchführt, ganz abstrakt gesprochen. Und der sorgt dafür, dass in die Umgebung Dinge abgestrahlt werden. Also ein Beispiel hatten wir Tempest die Funkwellen, das andere war die restlichen Ströme, die so auf einer Leitung langlaufen. Es gibt aber noch mehr Fälle. Zum Beispiel kann man auch Geräusche identifizieren. Das heißt, wenn man auf einer Tastatur tippt, macht jede Taste so ein bisschen ein anderes Geräusch. Und auch das kann man analysieren. Das fällt grob mit. Ja, geht sogar über Telefon.
Ich könnte jetzt mal ein Passwort raten.
Also das geht tatsächlich. Also es ist halt irgendwie nicht mit 100% die Wahrscheinlichkeit. Also es hat irgendwie immer so eine gewisse... Also man sollte halt schon wissen, welche Tastatur derjenige einsetzt. Und halt irgendwie so einen baugleichen Typ schon mal da haben und irgendwie mal 100 mal auf jede Taste drauf tippen und dann halt so eine Statistik drüber laufen zu lassen. Aber dann hat man halt sehr große Wahrscheinlichkeiten. Also irgendwie, das waren halt so 90, 95% mit der man halt die Tasten drückt.
Ich ruf also meine Freundin an, die ich gerade verdächtige, dass sie mit jemand anderem irgendwie zugang, und sag, hier log dich doch mal bei dem sozialen Netzwerk deiner Wahl ein und gib dein Passwort ein.
Genau. Also vielleicht nicht so plump und offensichtlich, aber...
Also nicht mal zwangsweise nur Passwörter, sondern du kannst natürlich dann halt die Chats irgendwie selber mithören.
Das ist viel zu anstrengend, weil ich das Passwort erst mal abgerichtet habe. Okay, however...
Geschichte war mal stehen geblieben, oder gibt es einen Anrufer?
Genau, es gibt einen Anrufer, den ich gerne reintun würde.
Markus, ich sehe die Anrufer nicht. Du hast vergessen das Programm zu starten.
Das machen wir gleich. Erst würde ich den Michel sozusagen zu uns bitten. Hallo und guten Abend. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob es jetzt zusammenpasst. Denn Michel hat eine Frage zu RFID. Stell mal die Frage und dann sagen wir dir, ob es zusammenpasst.
Ich wollte mal so fragen, ob dieses Tempo-Projekt, habt ihr ja gesagt, elektromagnetische Welten werden erfasst, werden analysiert und dann aufgewertet. Wie schaut das aus mit RFID? Ich meine, diese MyFlare-Chips, die werden ja recht gut oft verwendet. Menderkarten etc. Inwieweit kann man die denn so direkt auslesen? Nur wenn man die benutzt? Oder kann man natürlich, wenn man eine RFID-Lesegerät hat, natürlich die auch über Entschalung auslesen? Inwieweit wird das dann analysiert?
Wir haben uns vorhin schon gefragt, ob das im Allgemeinen noch zu Tempest zählt, also dieses RFID-Sache. Weil eigentlich ist das kein Tempest, weil ja die Daten absichtlich rausgesendet werden. Und Tempest ja eigentlich nur die unabsichtlich ausgesendeten Daten, also das Auffangen der Daten, irgendwie beinhaltet. Aber im weitesten Sinne kann man da sicherlich irgendwie auch als, da es halt elektromagnetisch abgestrahlt wird.
Die Ausstattung ist ähnlich, es ist auch elektromagnetische Abstrahlung. Man braucht ähnliche Geräte, um es zu empfangen und auszuwerten. Und der feine Unterschied ist der, dass ja so RFID absichtlich eine Funkwelle aussendet. So wie ein Radiosender absichtlich sendet. Oder wenn man eine drahtlose Tastatur hat, das sendet absichtlich. Oder ein WLAN oder oder oder oder. Und bei Tempest geht es eher darum, dass Sachen nicht senden sollen. Also wenn man halt keine drahtlose Tastatur hat, sondern eine mit einem Kabel dran, die trotzdem sendet. Darum geht es.
Aber zum Beispiel RFID gab es vor ein paar Monaten ziemlich gutes Beispiel, die Schweizer Passlesegeräte. Also wo der elektronische Reisepass ja irgendwie auch mit RFID ausgestattet wird. Die wurden mal von dem Bundesamt für Kommunikation in der Schweiz irgendwie getestet. Unter anderem auch der CrossMatch, der halt auch in Deutschland eingesetzt wird. Und da haben sie halt genau auch geguckt, bis zu welcher Entfernung halt diese Kommunikation zwischen Karte und Laser noch abgehört werden kann und sind halt drauf gekommen, dass es halt bis zu 25 Meter halt passiv mitlöschen sehr wohl geht. Und sie haben auch noch getestet, was wir halt gerade schon mal kurz angehört haben, dass die Informationen halt auch in das Stromnetz eingespeist werden. Das heißt irgendwie dieser Kartenleser steckt halt in der Steckdose drinnen. Und was sie gemacht haben, ist einfach irgendwie die nächste Steckdose im übernächsten Raum genommen, haben dich da halt irgendwie rangeklemmt und haben halt über den Stromverbrauch, beziehungsweise über die Strahlung, die auf der Stromleitung drauf ist, haben sie halt die Daten ausgelauscht.
Warte mal, die elektrische Abstrahlung geht so weit, dass ich habe ein Gerät, das verarbeitet Daten. Und das steckt natürlich in der Steckdose, weil es ja Strom braucht. Ich stecke nämlich eine andere Steckdose im selben Haus und kann dann auslesen, was da passiert?
Also die Daten, die ich dazu gefunden hab, waren, dass es bis zu 500 Meter durchaus noch machbar ist. Das heißt, du musst dich halt ins gleiche Haus, in den Keller setzen. Also musst du natürlich gut filtern können, weil du ein bestimmtes Ziel hast. Aber im Endeffekt, wenn du das nötige Equipment hast, dann geht das auf jeden Fall. Und das haben auch schon Leute gezeigt. Also irgendwie jetzt auf der, wie ist diese komische Konferenz in Las Vegas, die gerade stattfindet? Gibt es einen Vortrag dazu, ihr könnt ja mal Blackhead und Tempest bzw. Stromnetz, Powerline irgendwie googeln. Und da gibt es bestimmt eine Beschreibung dazu.
Und wenn ihr den Link habt, könnt ihr gleich ins Wiki schreiben. Zum Chaosradio, das gibt es nämlich. Was außerdem noch am Start, das ist ein IRC-Kanal, der ist bei, oh Gott, weißt du die Adresse? Freenote?
wirk.freenote.net. Und der Kanal heißt Raute Chaosradio.
Oder ihr geht einfach auf chaosradio.de, da gibt es auch einen Link zur aktuellen Sendung zum Wiki. Und da gibt es auch ein, na wie ihr einfach nur mit Browser in diesen Chat reinkommt ohne einen eigenen ERC Client. Alles kein Problem. So, Michel, ist das deine Frage? Ist sie beantwortet worden? Wunderbar. Dann viel Spaß mit deinen RFID Chips.
Also ich hab noch eine kurze Anmerkung zu den Leuten auf der Black Hat. Am besten mal nach Andrea Basani und Daniele Bianco googeln. Das sind die zwei, die das gemacht haben.
Jetzt sitze ich hier in meinem Studio und frage mich gerade so Habt ihr so ein ganz paar Geräte? Lassen sie sich den alle abhören? Also ich würde sagen, dass es geht, ist wahrscheinlich jetzt mittlerweile klar. Ich würde mal fragen, ob ihr das schaffen könnt. Da hätten wir zuerst hier meinen schönen kleinen Bildschirm, wo die Telefonanlage dran ist, wo ihr anrufen könnt. 0331 77 97 110 könntet ihr zum Beispiel sehen, wer jetzt gerade anruft.
Wenn du mir die Software starten möchtest, könntest du die drüben auch sehen.
Ja, das machen wir gleich, wenn die Nachrichten kommen. Genau, aber so das wäre möglich.
Also das ist halt ein LCD Display, haben wir ja vorhin schon angesprochen. Das ist nicht ganz so einfach, wie die alten Kartonstrahlröhren, aber ist auf jeden Fall machbar.
Was heißt machbar?
Na, wir machen das mal in einem anschaulichen Beispiel. Da gibt es diese Wahlcomputer.
Moment mal, okay.
Ja, die haben wir uns schon vor einer Weile mal angeguckt. 2006 war das in Holland. Die holländische Variante des Wahlcomputers, der auch in Deutschland hier eingesetzt wurde. Und da haben wir noch relativ simples Equipment gehabt. Da konnte man aber trotzdem, wenn man auf die richtige Frequenz gedreht hat, so einen Funkscanner, also einen Funkempfänger, was waren das für Frequenzen? Ich glaube auf 30 und auf 50 MHz, auf 150 MHz, wenn man das Signal gehört, konnte man das da ranhalten. Dann macht das... Fanden wir schon mal spannend. Wir konnten da nicht viel analysieren, weil dieser Empfänger keine besonders große Bandbreite hatte. Dann haben wir drauf rumgeklickt, dann macht das plötzlich nicht mehr brrrr, sondern brrrrrrr. Dann haben wir uns gewundert. Dann haben wir noch mal eine andere Taste gedrückt, dann macht das wieder brrrrr. Das haben wir eine Weile gemacht, dann haben wir rausgefunden, dass es da eine Partei gibt, nämlich die Konservative Partei in den Niederlanden. Da gibt es ein E mit einem Akzent drauf im Namen. Die anderen haben das nicht. Das ist also ein Sonderzeichen. Dieses Sonderzeichen, das kommt irgendwo aus diesem Display raus. Offensichtlich aus einem anderen Speicher, wo der Chip länger nachdenken muss, wo er das jetzt hernehmen muss.
Was sie gemacht haben, die normalen Buchstaben haben sie per ASCII-Zeichensatz genommen. Und dieses Akzent haben sie als Grafik dargestellt.
Genau, deswegen hat es länger gedauert. Und so ein Display, ich bin ja noch nicht ganz fertig. Ich bin jetzt noch mal fertig.
Ich glaube nur bei ASCII-Zeichen haben wir gerade mal Leute verloren. Es geht einfach darum, dass Buchstaben letztendlich auch nur Zahlen in dem Rechner drin sind. Und die normalen Buchstaben und die Buchstaben mit dem Sonderzeichen umdrehen, sind auf verschiedene Art und Weise abgespeichert worden.
Genau, und so ein Display, das wird ja immer so von links nach rechts dargestellt. So genannte Refresh sieht man ja auch an Monitoren, die flackern immer ein bisschen. Das ist bei den LCDs nicht anders. Und da er länger gebraucht hat, um sich diesen Buchstaben auszudenken, hat er also das Display nicht mehr so oft pro Sekunde neu gemalt. Und das war der Unterschied, den man hörte. Man hörte also den Refresh von einem Display, also die Bildwiederholfrequenz, und zwar verschiedene, je nachdem, ob mit Umlaut oder ohne Umlaut.
Wow, das heißt, man könnte quasi da zumindest diese eine Partei rausfinden. Also rausfinden, ob jemand konservativ will oder nicht.
Und das mit sehr, sehr einfachen Mitteln. Was man dazu braucht, war wirklich so ein Handscanner, den man für ein paar Euros im Laden kaufen kann.
Also schräg gegenüber von der Bildzeitung gibt es einen Laden, da kann man die kaufen.
Und es hat auch noch richtig weit gereicht. Also irgendwie halt über die Straße rüber, das waren auf jeden Fall 100 Meter, oder so konnte man halt noch sehen oder hören, beziehungsweise ob derjenige jetzt gerade die Konservativen gewählt hat oder nicht.
Ich überlege es gerade, wir haben in Deutschland nicht...
Wir haben die Grünen.
Ja, okay, aber wer wählt schon die Grünen nach der Sache mit den Netzsperren?
Wer wählt überhaupt noch nach der Sache mit den Netzsperren?
Das ist ein problematisches Thema. Jetzt müssen wir abschweifen. Wollen wir es bleiben lassen?
Also wenn ihr lieber jetzt darüber reden wollt, ob man noch irgendjemand wählen soll nach den Netzsperren, könnt ihr anrufen, 033 171 971 110. Ansonsten machen wir weiter mit Tempest, nämlich elektromagnetische Abstrahlung, die es ermöglicht, dass man aus Geräten herauslesen kann, was diese gerade machen, obwohl man das gar nicht will. Und damit geht es weiter nach der nächsten Musik. Die kommt direkt aus dem Netz und ist Creative Commons gedingst. Lizenziert ist das Wort, das ich gesucht habe und ist von Trekkie Birthday. Danach machen wir nach dem Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht es weiter mit dem Chaos Radio. I've clicked more than Douglas Engelbart.
I'm as bossy as Bowser. I need the internet like Whitney Houston needs crack.
Die neuste Musik kann man mit nicht nur auf Fritz hören, sondern auch fritz.de Jede Woche die besten neuen Videos zur besten neuen Fritz-Musik.
Präsentiert von Fritz und TAPETV. Gehst du fritz.de?
Guckst du rechts?
Kriegst du drauf? Bist du bei? Na schau mal einer an. TAPETV auf fritz.de Und da sieht man's um halb elf.
Nachrichten.
Mit Mario Bartsch.
Ein seit gestern Abend vermisstes Mädchen aus Eilenburg bei Leipzig ist tot aufgefunden worden. Die neunjährige Corinna sei vermutlich einem Gewaltverbrechen zum Opfer gefallen, teilten Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft mit. Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt könnten noch keine Aussagen zu den Todesumständen getroffen werden, da die gerichtsmedizinische Untersuchung noch bevorstehe. Suchkräfte hatten das Mädchen in einem Graben gefunden. Morgen wollen die Ermittler die Öffentlichkeit auf einer Pressekonferenz über den Fall informieren. Die Deutsche Krebshilfe warnt davor, ins Solarium zu gehen. Hauptgeschäftsführer Nettekofen sagte der neuen Osnabrücker Zeitung, er sei durch neue Forschungsergebnisse alarmiert. Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation hatte heute mitgeteilt, dass Sonnenbaden im Solarium genauso krebserregend ist wie Zigaretten und Asbest. Besonders gefährdet sind Leute unter 30. Im organisierten Drogenhandel werden in Berlin immer öfter Minderjährige als Dealer eingesetzt. Einige Familien würden gezielt unter 14-Jährige los schicken, weil die noch nicht strafmündig sind, hieß es von Berliner Drogenhilfeprojekt Fixpunkt. Vor allem in den U-Bahnen der Bezirke Kreuzberg, Neukölln und Wedding werden die jungen Drogendealer eingesetzt. Am Montag hatte die Polizei in Kreuzberg einen 12 Jahre alten Jungen gefasst, der 150 Heroinkügelchen dabei hatte.
Nach dem BMW aus in der Formel 1 nun gleich die nächste Sache.
Ja, das wollte ich eigentlich selber erzählen. Rekordweltmeister Michael Schumacher kehrt nach drei Jahren Pause in die Formel 1 zurück. Der 40-Jährige wird für den verunglückten Ferrari-Piloten Filippa Massa an den Start gehen, teilte der Schalte der italienische Rennstall in Rom mit. Massa war am Sonnabend in der Qualifikation zum großen Preis von Ungarn verunglückt und liegt seitdem im Krankenhaus. Schumacher erklärt auf seiner Internetseite, er könne aus Verbundenheit zum Team diese unglückliche Situation nicht ignorieren und freue sich auf die Herausforderung. Das nächste Rennen findet am 23. August in Valencia statt. Wetter Heute Nacht wird es recht mild, es bleibt weiter trocken bei einer Tieftemperatur von um die 13 Grad. Am Tag gibt es wieder etwas weniger Sonne, dann kann es auch wieder vereinzelt Gewitter oder Schauer geben, das Ganze bei maximal 27 Grad. A2 Berlin Richtung Magdeburg. Zwischen Wollin und Ciesa liegen auf der linken Spur Holzlatten, da bitte vorsichtig fahren. A9 Halle Leipzig Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Belitz und Belitz Heilstetten gibt es einen Unfall mit, oder gab es einen Unfall vielmehr mit einem LKW, da sind zwei Spuren gesperrt. In der Gegenrichtung ist die linke Spur gesperrt wegen Bergungsarbeiten. A10 westlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Werder. Zwischen Potsdam Nord und Leestgefahr durch eine ungesicherte Unfallstelle. Die rechte Spur ist blockiert. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin A115. Die AWUS, der Zubringer Nudetal, statt einwärts Richtung Berlin im Dreieckfunkturm. Also der Tangente in Richtung A100 gibt es eine Sperrung. Und B96 im Tunnel Tiergarten. Der ist zwischen Nord und Süd gesperrt nach einem Unfall. Sonst überall gute Fahrt.
Einfach mal zu Hause bleiben, Sachspa.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Prignitz.
Mit Markus Richter, Starbucks und Andreas Boke vom Chaos Computer Club. Wir erstrahlen heute nicht nur elektromagnetisch ab, wie man das als Radio so gemeinhalt tut, sondern wir reden auch noch darüber, wie man das Ganze so abhören kann, dass man daraus Dinge wissen kann, die man eigentlich gar nicht wissen darf. Aber bevor wir das machen, gibt's noch ein bisschen Musik, die euch auch noch im Netz ziehen könnt. Und zwar vom Metz und passend zum heutigen Thema heißt der Track Voices. Entschuldigung, ich hab da nichts mit der Technik und so weiter. Jetzt nochmal. Manny und Dave waren das in den Urlaub mit den Jungs. Sehr cool, Musik aus dem Netz, könnt euch da runterziehen. Und es gibt, ihr seid jetzt also ganz vor vorne, Chaosradio, Blue Moon, am letzten Mittwoch, Monat wie immer. Und es wurde gerade, es gibt einen Chat zur Sendung, der ist unter irc.freenote.net und dann Slash Hashtag Zeichen. Hashtag Zeichen, das heißt gar nicht so, das heißt Nummerzeichen. Genau. Raute Chaosradio könnt ihr mitmachen. Und das ist ein Chat, da geht es immer heiß herzu. Manchmal wird zur Sendung selbst diskutiert, aber so richtig hoch her geht es nur, wenn man Musik in dieser Talksendung spielt. Das geht doch nicht, oh geil Musik und so weiter und so fort.
Hip Hop, ey geil, Sprechgesang.
So sieht es aus. Das Schönste, was ich aber zur Sendung gelesen habe, habe ich bei Twitter jetzt gerade gelesen. Da schreibt nämlich Phil daf, ich muss aufhören Chaosradio zu hören. Ich bekomme dann immer meine paranoide Phase. Das liegt daran, dass wir heute über elektromagnetische Abstrahlung sprechen.
Deswegen ruft er wahrscheinlich auch nicht an, genauso wie die ganzen anderen Leute nicht. Das ist übrigens eine Anrufersendung.
Das stimmt, also wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr anrufen. Ihr müsst nicht, aber wenn ihr wollt, dann könnt ihr hier anrufen. Wobei ich das auch sehr spannend finde, dass keine Anruf, weil ihr habt ja selber erzählt, das ist eigentlich ein relativ interessantes Hacker-Thema. Man kann halt irgendwie von jedem technischen Gerät, das irgendwie Daten verarbeitet, die Abstrahlung messen und dann sagen, auf deinem Monitor guckst du dir gerade komische Bilder an oder guckst du dir gerade CDU-Wahlwerbung an. Also Dinge, die man lieber nicht von einem in der Öffentlichkeit haben möchte. Aber es ist relativ wenig verbreitet.
Also ich glaube, der Aufwand ist halt immer noch relativ hoch für den normalsterblichen Hacker. Also sowohl der Materialaufwand als auch der technische Aufwand.
Aber ihr meint jetzt auch für einen ganz großen Schein, also 1.000 Euro und ein bisschen Bust-A-Lie kriegt man das hin. Was ja eigentlich bedeutet, dass sozusagen, wenn ich jetzt eine mittelgroße Detektei betreibe zum Beispiel, ein bisschen Wirtschaftsspionage, da würde ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das eigentlich ein größeres Thema ist.
Also die auf jeden Fall. Für Wirtschaftsspionen ist Tempest das A und O. Also jetzt mit Internet und sowas ist das alles ein bisschen abgeklungen, aber halt irgendwie noch vor, sagen wir, zehn Jahren, wo es noch keine offenen WLANs gab, war garantiert 90 Prozent der Wirtschaftsspione irgendwie. Naja, wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so viel, aber auf jeden Fall. Tempest ist auf jeden Fall ein ziemlich angesagtes Thema.
Das heißt, es wird wieder so werden, wenn die Leute anfangen, ihr Internet ordentlich zu verschlüsseln, bzw. ihre Kommunikation über das Netz. Könnte man davon ausgehen?
Also ich habe den Eindruck, dass alles, was mit Signalverarbeitung zu tun hat, gerade wieder in wird. Also es haben die Leute sich echt lange Jahre nur mit Buffer-Overflows beschäftigt. Buffer-Overflows ungefähr die letzten zehn Jahre. Und dann waren da noch Buffer-Overflows und Exploits für Buffer-Overflows.
Ich mache mich vielleicht unbeliebt bei den Leuten, die im Chat sind und total den Plan haben, aber die spielen zu vieler Hip-Hop. Nee, ich wollte an dieser Stelle tatsächlich keine Musik spielen. Ich wollte einfach nur bitten, ob wir kurz Buffer-Overflows anschauen. Soll ich oder wollt ihr?
Okay, jetzt muss ich mal kurz und schmerzlos sein, bin ich gespannt.
Es geht ja nicht darum, wirklich zu begreifen, was Buffer-Overflow ist, aber damit eine Vorstellung hat. Buffer-Overflow ist das, was ein Programm zum Abstürzen bringen kann. Und wenn man das geschafft hat, kann man dann wiederum sozusagen den eigenen Code ausführen, den man damit reingibt. Das ist, glaube ich, schon mal mehr als...
Lass mal gelten, das ist mehr als nichts.
Und immerhin.
Ja, weiter geht's. Also erstens wird den Hackern langweilig und immer wieder was Neues machen. Und zweitens, wenn die Leute auch mehr ja war, das stürzt dann nicht mehr ganz so viel ab.
Das ist langsam, ne?
Nein, nicht mehr wirklich. Also Faktor 2 allerhöchstens. Und das ist man gerne bereit dafür auszugeben, dass der Kram hinterher funktioniert. Aber ja, deswegen werden solche Themen wie Tempest gerade wieder aktuell. Und alles, was mit Signalverwaltung zu tun hat, wir haben vorhin gehört, die Jungs, die die Stromversorgung des Hauses nachgemessen haben, um die Abstrahlung der Tastatur zu messen. Die hatten auch ein anderes interessantes Projekt. Da haben sie von hinten mit einem Laser auf den Laptop-Deckel drauf geleuchtet und sich das durch einen Fernrohr angeguckt und da auch wieder die Tastendrücke rekonstruieren können aufgrund der Vibration, die das gemacht hat. Ja, auch alles, was mit Funk zu tun hat, GSM und so weiter und so fort, das kommt gerade in Mode, kann man so sagen.
Aber wir hatten ja vorhin schon irgendwie den kleinen Streit, also sagen, ist das GSM, also Handyfunk, ist das sozusagen noch Tempest? Weil da wird ja auch damit, also da will man ja, dass das strahlt.
Nee, das ist kein Tempest mehr, aber es ist dieselbe Hardware, die man sich da kauft. Das sind dieselben 1000 Euro, die du ausgibst, um hinterher auch GSM machen und abfüllen zu können.
Das ergibt einmal viel Geld aus und kann dann richtig viel Spaß haben.
Also halt dieses Gnu-Radio, das macht halt wirklich irgendwie Aufsätze, also halt irgendwie Endgeräte für halt den gesamten Frequenzbereich, der derzeit in Benutzung ist, also zumindest bis 5 Gigahertz hoch. Das heißt, man kann halt irgendwie alles, was irgendwie elektromagnetisch abstrahlt, damit mehr oder weniger einfach aufnehmen. Also was man halt noch dazu braucht, sind halt ein paar Antennen, die passenden. Aber ansonsten reicht halt nur noch dieses Gnuradio.
Wie ist denn das mit den Antennen? Bei WLAN gab es damals irgendwie diese schönen Versuche, wie weit kann man das treiben? Da wurde irgendwie mit Chipsröhren und Alufolie rumgebastelt. Ist das bei Tempest auch so einfach oder muss man da schon eher?
Ja, eine sehr beliebte Antenne dafür ist die sogenannte Magnetic Loop Antenne, die also die magnetische Komponente des elektromagnetischen Fels auskoppelt. Und da kann man zum Beispiel einen Hula-Hoop-Reifen nehmen und einen Draht durchziehen.
Ehrlich?
Ist kein Witz.
Okay.
Also ich hab den gestern wieder in den Club zurückgebracht, nachdem wir irgendwie in Brandenburg waren, Tempest-Messungen machen und die Leute im Café gegenüber von meinem Auto haben auch sehr komisch geguckt, als ich mir den Hula-Hoop-Reifen mit dem Kabel draushängen, irgendwie über die Schulter geworfen hab.
Also ich dachte ja bis jetzt auch, aber irgendwie wenn die HKA vom Chaos Computer Club ihre Hardware zurück in den Club bringen, dass da irgendwie so komische Kisten mit Kabel draushängen, aber ein Hula-Hoop-Reifen, hätte ich jetzt nicht so richtig gedacht. Okay, ihr wart in Brandenburg messen, was wart ihr da messen?
Da sind wir wieder bei den Wahlen. Wir haben Wahlcomputern nachgemessen, und zwar nach der Geschichte 2006 in Holland, hat die PTB, die Physikalisch-Technische Bundesanstalt, die also auch für die Prüfung von Geldspielgeräten und Wahlcomputern zuständig ist, erklärt, sie hätten selbstverständlich die elektromagnetische Abstrahlung der Geräte gemessen und es hätte sich alles im Rahmen befunden und das Problem, das wir da gehabt hätten, das könnten sie überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen und überhaupt wäre alles sicher. Nur ist es nicht das erste Mal, dass die PTB irgendwelche Sachen erzählt hat, die nicht stimmen. Übrigens sind sie auch mit den Geldspielgeräten ganz furchtbar böse auf die Fresse geflogen. Das haben sie genauso wenig gut geprüft wie Wahlcomputer.
Weil, haben Geldspielgeräte jetzt auch mit Tempest zu tun?
Das gibt es da auch, diese Tempest-Geschichte.
Das finde ich ja noch mal richtig spannend, aber dazu später.
Aber das war nicht der Punkt, warum sie auf die Fresse geflogen sind.
Aber wir sind, wie gesagt, wir hatten eigentlich eine Liste vorliegen von der holländischen Prüf-Agentur, der holländischen Prüfbehörde, was die Unterschiede zwischen den holländischen und den deutschen Wahlcomputern ist. Weil nämlich die deutschen Wahlcomputer auch in Holland zur Wahl zugelassen waren, sind sie ja nicht mehr. Und da stand also drin, es waren fünf oder sechs Punkte, da stand so was wie der Abstimmknopf ist grün und nicht rot und der Abstimmknopf hat eine Folientastatur und ist kein Druckknopf. Und von zusätzlicher Abschirmung gegen Tempest stand da nichts. Also wir haben denen das nicht geglaubt und sind deswegen rausgefahren ins schöne Brandenburg, wo uns von einer Gemeinde einen, naja, zur Verfügung gestellt nicht möglich. Die haben also wirklich aufgepasst, dass wir das Gerät nicht mal wirklich anfassen, dass wir da nichts einbauen, vor allen Dingen nichts aufschrauben und auch nichts einspielen und so weiter und so fort.
Also sie haben nur noch nicht rausgefunden, warum sie uns eigentlich drangelassen haben, oder?
Ich glaube, sie waren auch neugierig. Aber wir durften Messung machen, wir durften uns mit der Antenne daneben stellen, wir durften mal ein paar Tasten drücken, eine Wahl simulieren und sie mal einer guck. Wir haben tatsächlich dieselben elektromagnetischen Abstrahlung gefunden wie vorher auch in Holland. Nur, dass wir diesmal etwas besseres Equipment dabei hatten, besagtes GNU Radio, was also auf einer höheren Bandbreite empfängt.
Und den Hula-Hoop-Reifen nicht zu vergessen.
Und den Hula-Hoop-Reifen nicht zu vergessen. Also der Scanner damals, der Funkscanner, mit dem wir damals in Holland den Empfang gemacht haben, der hat so 4 Kilohertz Bandbreite, das war Narrow FM. Und diesmal hatten wir mit dem GNU Radio 8 Megahertz Bandbreite.
Also 4 Kilohertz gegen 8 Megahertz, das reicht.
Das ist so wie ein Telefon gegen ganz schön High-Fi. Also 2000 mal so viel Information.
Eine Bandbreite abweckt.
Als alter Radiomensch, Unterschied zwischen Mittelwelle und UKW. Und wir sind noch nicht ganz fertig mit der Auswertung, aber wir können schon mal sagen, dass man sehr, sehr deutlich Muster sieht. Und zwar, also man hört nicht bloß Brrrr und Brrrr, sondern wenn man sich das Frequenzspektrum der Signale anguckt, die man da aufzeichnet, sieht man deutliche Unterschiede, je nachdem, was da auf dem Display dargestellt wird. Wir wieder zu der Frage zurückkommen, wie das ist mit den LCDs, wo ja immer eine Zeile beziehungsweise bei diesen Displays eine Spalte gleichzeitig dargestellt wird. Man kann die Pixel nicht komplett rekonstruieren. Man kann also nicht den Bildschirminhalt einfach so sichtbar machen, wie das bei den Röhrenmonitoren der Fall ist. Man kann aber für jede Zeile oder jede Spalte sagen, wie viele Pixel da gleichzeitig an sind. Wenn man sich mal überlegt auf so einem Wahlcomputer, die Anzahl der Displayinhalte, die ist ja endlich. Da steht dann immer der Name des Kandidaten, den man gerade ausgewählt hat. Dann fragt er einen, ob man fertig ist mit der Wahl oder nicht. Das heißt, es gibt da so 20 oder 30 verschiedene Displayinhalte.
Also bei der letzten Wahl waren es deutlich mehr. Also der Wahlzettel, der noch auf dem Wahlcomputer drauf war, der hat ungefähr, ich glaube, 100 Kandidaten oder so.
Aber wenn man sich das mal überlegt, kann man, also wenn man für jede Spalte weiß, wie viele Pixel da gesetzt sind, schon rekonstruieren, was da gerade angezeigt wurde, wenn man weiß, was da stehen könnte. Und wir sind also so weit, dass wir in dem Spektrum optisch schon die Unterschiede sehen. Wir können also sagen, irgendwie, das war die eine Anzeige, das war die andere Anzeige aufgrund des optischen Aussehens. Und der Sport besteht jetzt noch darin, eine Software zu schreiben, die das automatisiert durchführt, um dann zu beweisen, dass die PTB mal wieder nicht recht hatte.
Das heißt, es ist theoretisch denkbar, dass ihr irgendwann demnächst eine Apparatur, gesamte Software habt, die bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl eingesetzt so der Wahlcomputer zum Einsatz kommt, sagt, wer was wann gewählt hat.
Ja, also im Prinzip ist dieses... Ach so, richtig, das ist verboten, deswegen macht es keiner. Aber im Prinzip ja, es gab ja das Verbot des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes, weil ja nicht nachvollziehbar ist, wie dieses Wahlergebnis zustande kommt. Und jetzt denken die Hersteller drüber nach, man könnte da doch so Drucker einbauen, sie denken da an Nadeldrucker. Wenn ich Nadeldrucker höre, muss ich auch wieder an Tempest denken.
Die machen doch dieses schöne Geräusch, oder?
Die machen dieses Geräusch. Und man kann anhand des Geräusches rekonstruieren, was da ausgedruckt wurde. Und dieses Geräusch machen die auch als elektromagnetische Welle. Und falls die auf die doofe Idee kommen sollten, da irgendwas zu probieren, denke ich, dass wir das dann wieder auspacken müssen.
Das war doch nicht schon unser nächsten Schritt schon wieder.
Das ist kein Schritt, das ist eine Drohung.
Okay, wissen wir also, was passiert, wenn die Wahlcomputer wieder zum Einsatz kommen. Jetzt haben wir Niklas in der Leitung, der hat angerufen, weil er schon die Sendung gehört hat und dazu eine Frage hat.
Als erstes würde ich ganz gerne sagen, dass ich eigentlich ziemlich überraschend finde und ziemlich cool finde, dass man Monitore und im größten Teil Monitore über so eine große Distanz überwachen kann bzw. circa konstruieren kann, was da passiert ist. Wenn man das mit heutigen Techniken wie WLAN oder DECT vergleicht, WLAN und DECT, ist ja relativ einfach abzuhören. Ist das ja für die damaligen Zeiten, wenn man das damals schon wusste, auch eine richtig starke Hackingaktion gewesen. Die Frage wäre, lohnt sich das eigentlich noch, da solche Aktionen durchzuführen bzw. lässt sich die Hardware, die man dafür braucht, so komprimieren, dass man die in den Rucksack packen kann und dann alles auslesen kann oder kann man sich da einfach per WLAN massiv reinhacken mit ein paar Programmen und dann hat man die Daten.
Na also zum Thema, irgendwie kriegt man das in den Rucksack rein. Das ist auf jeden Fall mit Ja zu beantworten. Also das Gnu-Radio passt irgendwie so in eine kleine Tupadose, also vielleicht so 20 mal 20 oder irgendwie noch ein bisschen kleiner und ein Akku dazu. Also auf jeden Fall mobil auf jeden Fall zu machen. Das Problem ist halt eher ein bisschen die Antenne, weil man will natürlich möglichst große Antennen haben, um möglichst weit weg zu sein. Aber wenn man halt nahe genug rankommt, wie zum Beispiel in Nachbarräumen, dann reicht natürlich, oder halt mit dem Rucksack halt irgendwie direkt daneben, reicht natürlich auch eine kleine Antenne. Und ansonsten, natürlich lohnt sich das. Also das ist ja nicht nur so, dass man halt Monitore abhören kann, sondern man hat wirklich alle elektronischen Geräte strahlen in gewisser Weise irgendwie ihre Informationen, die sie verarbeiten oder darstellen, ab.
Tastaturen sind sehr beliebt.
Genau, Tastaturen sollte man vielleicht auch gleich noch mal drauf eingehen. Deswegen, also da gibt es halt ein riesengroßes Spielfeld, was halt irgendwie noch nicht wirklich ausgespielt, wo ausgereizt wurde. Und halt der Aufwand ist halt eigentlich nicht so groß. Also man braucht halt irgendwie diese 1000 Euro für das Blue Radio. Und ein bisschen irgendwie Software Skills, um da ein bisschen um zu programmieren.
Aber vier Semester Signalverarbeitung schadet auch nicht, aber da bin ich raus.
Hat man das schon früher gemacht oder die Technik ist mir allgemein nicht bekannt und ich interessiere mich eigentlich auch für solche Sachen.
Man hat das schon eine Weile gemacht. Also teilweise, also aufgefallen ist natürlich, dass es elektromagnetische Abstrahlung gibt relativ früh, weil die Geräte sich gegenseitig gestört haben. Also Stichwort elektromagnetische Verträglichkeit ist im Prinzip seit den 50ern bekannt. Ich kenne eine Geschichte aus den 70ern, da haben sich Jungs an eine Universität hingesetzt und haben ein Spiel programmiert und der Computer, auf dem sie dieses Spiel programmiert haben, der hatte keine Soundausgabe und die wussten aber, dass wenn man ein Radio zudicht an einen Rechner dran stellt, dass es Störgeräusche macht und die haben es also geschafft, die Soundausgabe dieses Spiels dadurch zu erzeugen, dass sie gezielt die richtigen Tempeststörgeräusche erzeugt haben.
Das ist schon echt großartig. Nein, das war halt ein Radio. Sie haben halt natürlich die gleiche Frequenzbereiche.
Die haben sozusagen über diese Abstrahlung dieselben Schwingungen erzeugt, die auch ein Radiosender erzeugt. Also natürlich ist es selbe elektromagnetische Schwingungen. Aber das Interessante ist, dass man die offensichtlich so modulieren kann, dass da wieder Töne bei rausfallen. Die ersten Veröffentlichungen dazu gab es, wie gesagt, in den 80ern. Und spätestens seitdem ist es wirklich in Einschlägenkreisen ein bekanntes Thema. Ich würde aber davon ausgehen, dass die richtigen Leute das schon seit den 50er oder 60er Jahren gemacht haben.
Einer von euch hatte vorhin auch gesagt, dass man nicht das komplette Bild wieder aufbauen kann. Also es ist nicht möglich theoretisch vom Nachbarn kostenlos TV zu gucken.
Wenn er noch einen Röhrenmonitor hat, dann schon.
Dann schon, aber dann lässt sich das komplette Bild rekonstruieren.
Aber dann kannst du immer nur das gucken, was er auch guckt, das ist ja langweilig.
Ja klar, aber nach der Technik, wie er das erzählt hat, sind das ja ein paar hundert Meter und es werden ja wohl noch ein paar Omis in die Umgebung sein.
Du meinst, du drehst die Antenne und guckst, ja das geht natürlich. Also die Antenne irgendwie dahin drehen, was irgendwie gerade dich interessiert.
Also so ein negativer Effekt ist, dass wenn mehrere Leute gleichzeitig mit einem Röhrenmonitor auf Fernsehen gucken, dann sieht man alle Bilder überlagert.
Man kann natürlich die Antenne relativ gut richten auch. Also hier bei Tempest kommt es ganz entscheidend auch drauf an. Also die Empfangshardware ist halt eigentlich straight forward, kann man irgendwie so kaufen. Was halt wichtig ist, wirklich eine gute Antenne zu haben, um genau den gezielten Frequenzbereich, den man haben will, irgendwie rauszufiltern. Und dadurch, dass die Strahlung ja ungewollt ist, ist es hier halt meistens auch sehr schwach, das heißt irgendwie, man muss halt das bisschen Information in dem Rauschen halt irgendwie rausfiltern und da ist halt sehr entscheidend, eine richtig gute Antenne zu haben. Deswegen halt auch diese große Hula-Hoop-Antenne, weil die halt einfach einen großen Durchmesser hat und deswegen halt viel Strahlung.
Und nicht zu vergessen, die Viersemestersignalverarbeitung.
Genau.
Niklas, würdest du denn eigentlich, wenn du jetzt die Möglichkeit hättest, tatsächlich irgendwie losgehen und mal so Sachen in der Nachbarschaft abhören?
Die werden ja keine Daten veröffentlicht, würde ich jetzt mal so sagen. Also WLAN, ja schon ausprobiert, auch in der Stadt, hat geklappt. Mehrfach. Fernseher wird sich für mich nicht lohnen.
Ja, aber es gibt Geräte zum Beispiel auch mit Tastaturen.
Ja, ja okay, aber da ist es schon wieder viel einfacher, einfach einen Trojaner zu bauen und den dann über Usenet oder so.
Nee, nee, nee, ist es nicht. Es gab auch gerade vor ein paar Wochen erst oder vor ein paar Monaten irgendwie die Veröffentlichung, wo sich halt ein paar Leute halt hingesetzt haben und halt genau diese Funk-Tastaturen sich mal angeguckt haben und haben halt genauso auch für minimalen Aufwand, ich glaube der finanzielle Aufwand war irgendwie 20 Euro oder sowas und halt ein bisschen zusammengelötet. Also gibt es halt auch alles fertig im Netz zu klicken. Wir haben halt wirklich einen Empfänger gebaut, der halt diese Funk-Tastaturen abhört und halt die nicht wirklich vorhandene Krypto da drauf halt irgendwie raus extrahiert. Das heißt, man kann halt damit auch die die Tastaturen, Funk-Tastaturen abhören und halt mit wirklich geringem Aufwand.
Ja, ich glaube aber, das wird sich nicht so wehklohnen, wenn ich das vergleiche. Ja, wie ich manche kenne, die das wirklich machen mit Tausenden von Trojanern, die werden am Tag ein paar hundert Accounts von irgendwelchen Seiten bekommen. Dagegen muss es dann rumlaufen und irgendwelche Funk-Tastaturen, wenn überhaupt die Leute die haben.
Du willst ja nicht die Informationen von irgendwelchen komischen Kiddies haben, die irgendwie nur zocken auf ihren Rechnern und sich da interessieren. Naja, aber ich meine, es gibt natürlich Bereiche, wo halt Leute nicht mehr so doof sind und sich irgendwie Trojaner auf ihren Rechnern installieren lassen, wohingegen halt gegen Tastaturabstrahlung kann man halt nicht so wirklich viel machen bzw.
Oder sie haben ein ordentliches Betriebssystem.
Das hilft ja auch nur so eingeschränkt. Sie haben Computer beim Arbeitsamt, hab ich gehört, ja.
Also auch hier hochviel, also es geht halt nicht nur bei Funktastaturen, sondern auch bei normalen Tastaturen. Der Vorteil bei Funktastaturen ist, dass sie halt absichtlich funken. Das heißt, irgendwie die Signalstärke deutlich höher ist und man halt von viel weiter weg und mit einfacheren Mitteln die Informationen rauskriegt. Aber prinzipiell geht es halt wirklich auch mit allen anderen normalen Tastaturen, die man an den Port anschließt und dann drauf rumhackt. Und das kann man auch nicht verschlüsseln. Das kann man natürlich verschlüsseln.
Verschlüsseln ist schwierig, weil das ist der Strom, der durch die Taste fließt, wenn du den Knopf gedrückt hast. Da ist nicht viel zu verschlüsseln. Man kann es abschirmen oder man kann einen Störsender daneben stellen. Das sind so die Optionen, die man da hat.
Naja, aber wenn ich zum Beispiel den PC mit einem Programm vorher sage, wenn ich auf A drücke, ist das in Wirklichkeit Z oder 5, dann kann der, der das abhört, natürlich bekommt er irgendeinen Quatsch und ich habe die richtigen Eingaben.
Naja, aber dann musst du jetzt sagen, deine Tastatur umlernen. Da wünsche ich viel Spaß bei.
Also das kannst du machen, aber es ist ein so- und hat das Substitution-Cypher und da muss man eigentlich bloß lange genug beim tippen zugucken und dann guckt man sich die Häufigkeit der Buchstaben an, die da angekommen sind und dann weiß man, wie du deine Tasten vertauscht hast. Also hilft nicht viel.
Und sauber bleiben, ne Niklas? Sehr gut.
Ich hab noch eine Geschichte, weil Andreas gerade das erzählt hat mit der Soundkarte, also der fehlenden Soundkarte und dem Radio nebenan. Was auch gemacht wurde, ist die Funkuhrsignale, also DCF 77, mit einer Grafikkarte zu emulieren. Also da auch der gleiche Punkt, die Signale sind bekannt, wie sie decodiert sind, wie sie codiert sind, das heißt, man kann mit relativ einfachen Mitteln die Grafikkarte dazu überreden, genau in dem Frequenzbereich diese Bits umkippen zu lassen und damit zumindest in der Nähe der Grafikkarte die Funkuhr anstellen zu können. Was hat passiert ist, ein paar Brasilianer, ich kenne die Story von dem, der das mal geschrieben hat, dieses Tool, und er meint, er kriegt jetzt noch Mails von Leuten aus Südamerika, die sich auf ihren Deutschland oder in Europa besuchen, eine Funkuhr gekauft haben, und da drüben gibt es natürlich keinen DCF77-Sender, und sie versuchen jetzt krampfhaft ihre Uhr zu stellen und haben deswegen im Internet nach diesem Programm gesucht und stellen jetzt ihre Funkuhr mit ihrer Grafikkarte.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man mit Tempest auch was Sinnvolles machen kann. Naja, eine bleibt noch im Chaos Radio, wo es heute um Tempest geht und damit bezeichnet man elektromagnetische Abstrahlung beziehungsweise das Abhören derselben. So, jetzt haben wir noch eine Stunde, es ist quasi Halbzeit. Hier rufen wir heute nicht so viele Leute an, wahrscheinlich weil sie alle wie gebannt vor dem Monitor sitzen und sich fragen, wer gerade alles zuguckt und ausliest, was sie da so für Schweinkram treiben. Wir könnten jetzt Musik spielen. Oder nicht, was meint ihr?
Ich bin für Musik.
Ganz basisdemokratisch machen wir das jetzt?
Ich enthalte mich.
Du gehst ja auch nicht wählen.
Das habe ich nicht behauptet, ich habe bloß gesagt, das ist eigentlich gar kein Sinn.
Darüber machen wir jetzt den Mantel des Schweigens und hören ein paar Stimmen. Das war jetzt aber METZ mit Voices, auch Musik, die man einfach so aus dem Netz ziehen kann, weil sie in der Creative Commons Lizenz steht. Und mir ist zu Ohren gekommen, dass es einige Leute gibt, die nicht einverstanden sind mit der Musik, die hier gespielt wird und dass andere Leute nicht so genau verstehen, worum es hier geht. Und ich kann euch nur sagen, wenn ihr ein Problem habt und was genauer wissen wollt, dann gilt ganz einfach Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 Wenn Andreas und Starbuck vom Chaos Computer Club, die hier sind und heute darüber sprechen, wie man durch die elektromagnetische Abstrahlung von Geräten Dinge herausfinden kann, sind bereit, euch jede Frage zu beantworten, die ihr dazu habt. Und zwar noch bis Mitternacht. Auch der Thomas hat angerufen. Hi Thomas!
Hallo! Ich hab neulich ein relativ komisches Phänomen gehabt. Ich hab mir ein neues Mainboard für meinen Computer gekauft und hab meine Teile wieder schön zusammengesteckt und konnte daraufhin an meiner Soundkarte hören, wie stark mein Prozessor Unterlast war. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das vielleicht was mit Tempest zu tun hatte, dass irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, irgendwelche Schaltkreise da drin genau die elektromagnetischen Wellen ausgesendet haben, die irgendwelche Schaltkreise in meiner Soundkarte dazu gebracht haben, einen Ton auszuwenden.
Das ist durchaus wahrscheinlich, ja. Also die Frage ist, ob halt irgendwie dein Prozessor das gemacht hat oder vielleicht ein Lüfter. Aber auf jeden Fall irgendwas hat das schon gesendet und hat irgendwie auch in die Soundkarte eingekoppelt. Also bei Notebooks hat man zum Beispiel relativ oft, dass der WLAN-Funkchip halt irgendwie in die Soundkarte eingekoppelt bzw. der Display-Controller. Und wenn man zum Beispiel eine schnelle Wechsel von hell auf dunkel auf dem Display umschaltet, hat man so ein Fiepen bzw. ein Knacken hört. Also das ist durchaus nicht ungewöhnlich.
Es muss aber nicht unbedingt Tempest sein, sondern es kann sich sozusagen um den generischen Fall der Side-Channels handeln. Also was bei Soundkarten, Seitenkanäle, wir hatten es vorhin davon, dass ja auch Geräusche mittlerweile möglicherweise Dinge verraten oder der Stromverbrauch und das ist so eine Stromverbrauchsgeschichte, weil so eine CPU, je nachdem, was sie rechnet, da sind da so Nullen und Einsen und die werden in Kondensatoren gespeichert und die müssen und damit der Rechner rechnen kann, mal mit Strom befüllt werden und mal wieder von Strom entleert werden und je nach dem verbrauchen die gerade mehr oder weniger Strom und das führt natürlich dazu, dass der Spannungslevel der Stromversorgung sich ändert, je nachdem, ob die CPU gerade viel oder wenig Strom braucht. Das ändert sich abhängig davon, welche Daten verarbeitet werden.
Das wäre relativ wahrscheinlich, denn man konnte eben, also an der Tonhöhe dieses Gromens, konnte man feststellen, wie stark der Prozessor unter Last war. Also wenn er unter Last war, dann war das eine sehr tiefe Suche. Und das wurde richtig, naja, nicht fliegend, aber doch schon deutlich höher von der Tonhöhe, wenn man den auf 50, das ist ein Dualcore, oder auf 100% Last gebracht hat.
Das kann gut sein. Und das hört man natürlich auf der Soundkarte, wenn die mal mehr oder mal weniger Strom auf den Verstärker tut, dann ist es halt kurz lauter oder leiser, dieses Nullsignal, was da kommt. Interessanterweise, es gibt eine Veröffentlichung, da wurde der kryptographische Schlüssel einer RSA- Operation aus einem Rechner rausextrahiert. Und zwar eine ganz ähnliche Geschichte, da ging es auch um die Stromversorgung. Allerdings, also die Spannung in so einem Computer wird ja von einem Spannungsregler konstant gehalten. Und diese Spannungsregler haben manchmal die Eigenschaft, dass sie Geräusche machen. Also wenn man viele Lüfter in seinem Rechner hat, hört man das nicht. Bei Notebooks hört man es manchmal. Wenn man eine Wasserkühlung hat, die sehr leise ist, hört man das auch.
Ist es so ein leichtes Fiepen?
So ein leichtes Fiepen.
Das macht mich wahnsinnig.
Ich habe extra die 100 Euro mehr ausgegeben für ein Mainboard, wo die Spannungsregler nicht fiepen. Und die haben echt ein Mikrofon in den Rechner reingehalten und waren in der Lage, daraus den Schlüssel, also den privaten, geheimen, kryptographischen Schlüssel zu extrahieren.
Das ist ja schon einer von den Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen, die noch relativ gut dabei sind, oder? Ja, ja.
Das ist einer von den guten. Das sind diese asymmetrischen, die bei PGP verwendet werden oder wenn du per SSL auf eine Webseite gehst. Das ist schon so eine ganz schöne Standardgeschichte.
Mit einem Mikrofon.
Dann hätte ich noch eine Idee, wo man Tempest einsetzen kann für, ich sag mal, kriminelle Zwecke. Also es gibt ja noch Leute, die haben einen analogen Telefonanschluss. Und in den Fällen läuft ja das Signal auch noch analog vom Telefon, irgendwie, ich glaube 60 Hertz, glaube ich, bis zum Vermittlungskasten, der irgendwo im Dorf oder in der Stadt am Straßenrand rumsteht. Na und wenn man dort jetzt die Abstrahlung dieses Kabels oder dieses Anschlusses abhören könnte, kann man dann abhören, was der da am Telefon bremelt?
Man hat Übersprechen zwischen Telefonladung, das ist richtig. Also jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen weiter auswählen. Diese Kästen, die da rumstehen, das sind in aller Regel nicht die Vermittlungsstellen, sondern das sind die VDSL-Knoten, die sie jetzt überall hingestellt haben.
Analog, meint er.
Analog geht aber bis in die Vermittlungsstellen, das sind nicht die Kästen, die auf der Straße stehen.
So, das ist... Nee, früher hatten sie die Analog-Leitung halt direkt bis, also auf der Straße auch noch analog. Also konnte es sich halt mit dem Telefon oben raufstecken und hast halt irgendwie die Analog-Signale da rausgedrückt.
Ja, dass es raufklemmen geht, aber was man auch hat, ist übersprechen. Das heißt, wenn man so eine Telefonleitung hat, die man gerade nicht benutzt und die zufällig denselben Kabelweg verwendet, kann man möglicherweise mit viel Verstärkung noch hören, was da gesprochen wird. Also müsste gehen, ich hab's nie ausprobiert.
Also ansonsten, immer wenn es über Kabelinformationen rübergeht, um das Kabel rum halt die Antenne legen und dann braucht man halt nicht mehr wirklich viel Verstärkung, weil man halt schon ziemlich nah an den fließenden Bits dran ist. Elektronen.
Das ist schon sportlich. Dann wünsche ich euch noch viel Spaß und Chaos Radio.
Ich hatte zwei Fragen im Chat gerade gehabt. Die erste war die Qualität des Bildes bei diesem Röhrenmonitor mit einem Fernseher Heck. Also ich kenne halt auch nur irgendwie Fernsehberichte, wo sie es mal gezeigt haben, aber die Qualität war halt schon relativ gut. Also man konnte halt normale Schriftgröße konnte man halt auf dem Fernseher schon darstellen und lesen. Also beziehungsweise es war ein bisschen größere Schrift. Aber ich glaube, das Problem lag halt eher daran, dass der Fernseher selber halt nur eine definierte Auflösung hat. Das heißt, wenn man da mit einem höher aufgelösten Fernseher auf der anderen Seite abgehört hätte, hätte man wahrscheinlich auch die kleine Schrift gelesen können. Und die zweite Frage war zum Thema Abhören von Festplatten. Da muss ich ein bisschen weiter ausholen, oder?
Okay, ich hole mal ein bisschen weiter aus. So, jetzt wird es spannend für die Leute, die sich vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit Technik auskennen. Wir hatten es ja vorhin von der Leitung in dem dunklen schwarzen Raum, wo der Strom durchfließt. Jetzt wissen wir ja, wir haben es mit Computern zu tun. Da gibt es Nullen und Einsen, also Rechtecksignale. Das heißt, dass jedes Mal, wenn die Leitung ihren Zustand von 0 auf 1 ändert, oder wenn sie ihn von 1 auf 0 ändert, sich der Strom ändert, der durch die Leitung durchfließt und dann an dieser Stelle entsteht so eine elektromagnetische Welle, die man messen kann. Ja, jetzt ist so eine Leitung ja nicht perfekt. Das heißt, auch das Rechtecksignal, was da drauf liegt, ist nicht perfekt, sondern man kann sich vorstellen, es handelt sich dabei um einen Tiefpass. Das heißt, wenn man da mit dem OSC drauf guckt auf diesen Rechteckimpuls, dann wackelt der so ein bisschen rum, dann geht es schräg runter, dann wackelt es wieder ein bisschen. Und dementsprechend sieht das Signal aus, dass da abgestrahlt wird. Und je nachdem, wie lang jetzt diese Leitung ist und wie weit die von Masse weg ist, also abhängig von ihrer Induktivität und ihrer Kapazität, ergeben sich andere Filte-Eigenschaften des physikalischen Systems, das ich da anrege. Und dementsprechend gibt es auch Unterschiede. Das heißt, was man ja bei Festplatten hat, was man genauso bei den LC-Displays hat, was man auf Bus-Signalen hat und so weiter und so fort, ist ja, dass diese Bits alle gleichzeitig schalten. Und irgendwie in erster Näherung sieht man halt, wie viele Bits umgekippt sind. Das ist das, was wir bei den Wahlcomputern machen. Aber die sind ja alle ein kleines bisschen anders, diese Leitungen. Verhalten sich alle ein kleines bisschen anders. Und ich habe die Theorie, ich habe dazu keine Anhaltspunkte, ob es schon mal jemand getan hat, dass man die Leitungen voneinander unterscheiden können müsste. Dass man also, wenn man genau genug hinhört, die sind sozusagen alles ein bisschen anders gestimmt. Und wenn man genau genug hinhört, kann man die Töne auseinanderhalten. So kann man sich das glaube ich vorstellen. Und wenn man das kann, dann kann man wahrscheinlich auch Festplatten abhören.
Okay, aber das ist schon noch Zukunftsmusik.
Für mich jedenfalls. Das Problem ist, darüber ist so gut wie gar nichts publiziert. Also was es publiziert gibt, sind diese ganzen Analogmonitor-Geschichten. Zu Tempest von Digital-Signalen habe ich genau eine Veröffentlichung gefunden. Die kam von den Chinesen aus dem Jahre 2006 auf einer Robotikkonferenz. Also völlig themenfremd. Keine Ahnung, wie das da hingekommen ist. Die sich so mit den theoretischen Grundlagen beschäftigt hat. Ansonsten gibt es nicht viel. Der Rest ist eine Spekulation und darüber nachdenken, wie es funktionieren könnte.
Also wenn da draußen jetzt jemand sitzt, der weiß, wie man Festplatten Tempest abhört, bitte anrufen. 0331 70 97 110. Und was ich an dieser Stelle zusagen möchte, wenn ihr anruft, müsst ihr nicht Thomas heißen. Wir haben nämlich irgendwie jetzt gerade Thomas in der Leitung gehabt. Wir haben jetzt noch zweimal Thomas in der Leitung. Ihr dürft auch anrufen, wenn ihr Manfred heißt. Nein, alle Namen sind zugelassen. Einfach anrufen. 0331 70 97 110.
Dann nimm nochmal Thomas rein.
Ich nehm jetzt Thomas rein.
Hallo, ob die andere jetzt auch eine Logik sagt hat.
Hallo, du mit den Cut-Kabeln.
Ja genau.
Du bist das.
Ja, ich wollte mal fragen, wie das ist. Also diese Cut-Kabel.
Halt, was sind Cut-Kabel?
Na, das sind diese ganz normalen Internetverbindungs-Kabel oder LAN-Kabel oder Netzwerkabeln. Und ich wollte mal fragen, wie es da mit der Abhörsicherheit aussieht. Ich weiß, da gibt es ja welche, die hier geschirmt sind und wieder welche, die nicht geschirmt sind. Und diese Geschirrmten, reicht das aus oder kann man da immer noch Sachen abhören?
Also die strahlen in der Tat nicht besonders viel ab, weil die also die Menge Energie, die durch Abstrahlung in den Raum abgegeben wird, ist ja sozusagen auch die, die verloren geht und nicht am anderen Ende ankommt. Wenn man so auf der einen Seite Energie reinsteckt, ist wie so ein Wasserschlauch mit Löchern drin, kommt irgendwie, was nicht an der Seite rausgeht, kommt am Ende an. Und deswegen werden die natürlich so gebaut, dass möglichst viel am Ende ankommt. Also erstens sind das so genannte Twisted Pair-Kabel, das heißt, das sind immer pärchenweise Adern miteinander verdrillt, wo der Strom in der einen Richtung hinläuft und in der anderen Richtung zurückläuft. Dadurch heben sich die magnetischen Felder gegenseitig auf. Und wenn man also eine absolut ideal verdrillte Leitung hat, dann ist theoretisch das Feld, das da abgestrahlt wird, null. In der Praxis siehst du also nur die Abstrahlung durch die Toleranzen beim verdrillen. Und dann ist da ja bei modernen Kabeln, über die ein Gigabit drüber geht, noch eine Abschirmung drumrum. Das heißt, du kriegst in der Regel da nicht viel raus. Was ich allerdings mal gesehen habe, total clevere Erfindung damals, als die Leitungen noch nicht so schnell waren, war so eine, wie so eine Art Nadel mit Blech hinten dran, die man einfach auf das Kabel draufsteckt und also durch die Abschirmung durch, mitten rein, und die dazu führt, dass also mehr Energie abgestrahlt wird, was man dann im Kommunal-Zoo mit einem Empfänger draußen verwendet.
Das ist aber echter Agentenkram, oder?
Ja, das ist echter Agentenkram, so wie in den schlechten Filmen. Kommt einer rein, macht kurz Pieks in die Leitungen, geht schnell wieder raus.
Dann musst du Druckluftschläuche drumrum machen, dann musst du mal in den Druck gucken, ob der gleich bleibt.
Das haben sie in der Tat auch gemacht.
Die großen Telekom-Leitungen, die unterirdisch verlegt sind, sind alles Druckleitungen.
Genau.
Okay, jetzt neuer interessante Sachen. Wir haben ein Telefonkabel. Das soll nicht abgehört werden. Da wird drumrum eine Leitung gemacht. Du hast die einzelnen Kupferdrähte.
Außen hast du noch einen großen Mantel aus Plastik oder Rohre. Du hast Druckluft drin. Sie messen den Luftdruck. Wenn ihr abfällt, wissen sie, dass irgendwo ein Problem aufgetreten ist, dass das Kabel beschädigt ist. Ein Problem aufgetreten? Was sie noch tun, ist, die Luft ist mit radioaktiven Isotopen versetzt. Sie rennen mit einem Geigerzähler oder ähnlichen Geräten durch die Tunnel und können so relativ schnell das Lack finden.
Das ist ja großartig. Das ist ganz normale Technik, sag ich mal.
Das liegt im Normalen. Ich war mal vor ein paar Jahren in so einem Kabelschacht unten und ich wusste nicht, dass das Druckluft geschirmte Kabel waren und hab da halt mal ein bisschen herum geschnitzt und dann hat es auf einmal irgendwie zisch gemacht und ich hatte glücklicherweise noch irgendwelche Aufkleber in meiner Tasche, die ich dann schnell auf diesen Schlauch gepappt hab und dann irgendwie möglichst schnell wieder aus dem Tunnel geflohen bin.
Also liebe Telekom-Techniker, falls ihr da irgendwie so Punkband-Aufkleber auf euren Leitungen findet, wir wissen auch nicht, wer das war. Thomas, ist deine Frage damit beantwortet?
Jo, ich wollte noch was zu dem Thema vorher sagen, wo jemand gesagt hat, dass er gehört, wie viel Strom hat gerade sein Prozessor verbraucht. Ich hatte es mal so, wenn ich an meinem Soundcard direkt den Kopfhörer anschließe, dann konnte ich hören, wann ich klicke und welche Taste ich auf der Tastatur drücke.
Alles dasselbe. Seitenkanalangriffe, Tempest.
Wir sollten vielleicht mal ein bisschen was dazu erzählen, wie man sich gegen solche Tempeststrahlung schützen kann.
Ich hätte aber hier noch einen Thomas in der Leitung.
Dann gibt doch mal Thomas vor.
Lieber mal den Thomas in der Leitung geben.
Genau, aber das mit dem sagen, wir schützen uns davon, machen wir auf jeden Fall. Ich würde so ganz teasermäßig sagen, machen wir dann in der letzten halben Stunde nach Nachricht.
Super.
Jetzt erstmal Thomas. Hi Thomas.
Thomas. Der hat bestimmt vorhin schon rangehen wollen, dann verzweifelt aufgelegt.
Ah, das ist Thomas und ich, oder? Super, irgendwie bin ich auf den Hut gekommen. Dumme Sache. In der Tat.
Hast jetzt in deinem Telefon geschrien, ohne dass wir geantwortet haben.
Ja, eben. Das mit dem zum Thema schützen ist eigentlich ganz gut, weil dazu habe ich eigentlich auch eine Frage. Und zwar, ich meine, wie schützt ihr euch eigentlich? Also ich meine, ich habe immer so ein bisschen, dass ich führe, je mehr man über solche Technik erfährt, so je paranoider wird man auch ein Stückchen weit. Festzattel vor Schlüsseln tun ja nun sehr viele. Belastet ihr uns auch dabei oder schützt ihr euch auch gegen sowas? Oder wie weit geht das bei euch?
Also wenn du die Wettkämpfe guckst, die haben alles hin, voll Hits auf.
Ja, genau so. Hüte aus Alufolie. Die gegen die böse Röntgestrahlung. Nee, was soll man da sagen? Also es gibt irgendwo eine Grenze, wo wenn du dich mit bestimmten Leuten anlegst, die besser sind als du. So möchte ich das mal ausdrücken. Und das muss man halt einfach einsehen, dass irgendwann hat das einfach keinen Zweck mehr. Und solange man sich mit diesen Leuten nicht anlegt, dann muss man auch nicht paranoid werden.
Also alle, die jetzt zu paranoid sind, sollten jetzt weghören.
Also das heißt, dass man so abgehört werden kann, aber ihr sagt, das Risiko ist so gering, dass das Interesse bei jemanden euch abzuhören so groß ist, so was zu tun, dass ihr sagt, Festplattenverschließung reicht.
Also der Aufwand, das zu tun, ist halt immer noch relativ groß, beziehungsweise halt auch so der personelle Aufwand. Das heißt, du musst halt schon jemand haben, der den Lieferwagen vor deine Tür fährt oder irgendwie die Wand in deine Wohnung oder vor deine Wohnung platziert und es dann auswertet. Und auf der anderen Seite ist der Aufwand, sich halt wirklich hundertprozentig zu schützen, halt irgendwie auch extrem. Also man kann halt irgendwie mal was gegen die Abstrahlung von der WLAN-Karte oder vom Monitor tun, aber jetzt wirklich alles auszuschließen. Also auf allen Wegen sich zu schützen, das ist nahezu unmöglich.
Es kann einem natürlich passieren, dass man aus Versehen in seiner Diplomarbeit das Wort Gentrifizierung verwendet und dann hat man die Jungs jahrelang an der Backe. Es ist ja heutzutage nicht mehr ausgeschlossen, dass sie tatsächlich den Aufwand treiben.
Zu diesem Thema empfehle ich den Podcast der letzten Trackback-Sendung zu finden auf trackback.fritz.de. Da ist ein Interview mit jemanden, der Gentrifikation in seiner Arbeit benutzt hat und deswegen jahrelang abgehört wurde.
Ja, aber da kann man auch nichts machen. Das muss man dann einfach zur Kenntnis nehmen. Ganz großartig, ich hab mal eine Geschichte gelesen von jemanden, der vermutete damals noch zu DDR-Zeiten, er wird von der Stasi überwacht und hat dann also zu Weihnachten am Telefon gesagt, ach und übrigens grüßt sich noch die Mitarbeiter der Staatssicherheit, hat dann nach der Wende seine Akte gelesen, da stand dann fein säuberlich notiert, Herr so und so grüßt die Mitarbeiter der Staatssicherheit.
Okay, aber das kann man jetzt nicht wirklich zum Anlass nehmen und sagen, okay, sie sind wirklich überall. Diese Tempest-Sachen würden wir heute reden. Das ist jetzt nicht das Werkzeug für so 1980-Geschichte.
Das ist noch nicht die Massenüberwachung. Die Massenüberwachung sind Geschichten wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo wirklich jeder überwacht wird, wo die Daten rausfallen, wo drin steht, wo sich welches Handy zu welchem Zeitpunkt aufgehalten hat, wer mit wem telefoniert hat. Das ist die wirkliche Massenbedrohung, wo sich auch jeder verfolgt fühlen muss.
Also man braucht den Aufwand einfach gar nicht zu treiben, um Tempest-Strahlung zu messen und auszuwerten, sondern man hat heutzutage mit Bundestreuern, mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung, mit großem Lauschangriff und viel einfache Möglichkeiten an alle diese Informationen vor allem auch vollautomatisch im Endeffekt ranzukommen. Also auch von einem großen Anteil der Bevölkerung.
Tempest ist sozusagen mehr oder weniger so eine Art sportliche Herausforderung.
Tempest ist halt eher für Leute, die sich wirklich extrem schützen, gerade im industriellen Bereich, wo halt finanzielle Aufwendungen, bzw. das Aufwand, also Wirtschaft, viel Geld oder Geheimnisse oder beides. Also halt irgendwie Sachen, wo man die mal schützen sollte, um Vorteile gegenüber seinen Konkurrenten zu haben und da wirklich großen Aufwand treibt. Und da ist auf der anderen Seite Tempest-Sachen wieder lohnenswert, weil dann auch der Gewinn in dem Fall groß genug ist. Aber halt für die normale Abhöraktion gibt es halt andere Möglichkeiten.
Also ich muss da immer an der Staatsfeind Nummer 1 denken. Weil da war ja zum Schluss auch Gene Hackman in seinem Käfig, den er sich da gebaut hat, um hier ja nicht nach außen abzustrahlen und so was.
Ja, also die Filmemacher haben schon ein bisschen recherchiert, bevor sie angefangen zu drehen. Das stimmt. Sowas kann man tun. Also das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik gibt ja den Grundschutzkatalog heraus und da gibt es diverse Maßnahmen und da gibt es zum Beispiel die Maßnahmen M489 Abstrahlsicherheit, die sich dem Thema Tempest widmet. Und ja, so seine Wohnung mit Aluminiumfolie tapezieren, alles ordentlich erden kann man machen, muss man aufpassen, dass man die Stromleitung nicht vergisst. Also wenn man es wirklich gründlich macht, muss man sich einen Generator und einen Motor hinstellen mit einer elektrisch nicht leitenden Welle dazwischen, damit man auch das entkoppelt oder ähnliche Geschichten. Abstrahlsichere Geräte kaufen.
Also prinzipiell kann man halt erstens versuchen, die Geräte selber zu schützen gegen Abstrahlung. Das heißt, dass die Strahlung nicht aus den Geräten rauskommt. Dann kann man natürlich die Wohnung selber nochmal abstrahlsicher machen. Also wie gesagt, Kupfertapete oder bedampfte Scheiben. Was man natürlich noch machen kann, ist Sulfiridkerne. Was ist das? Tiefpass? Hochpass? Tiefpass. Genau diese Oberwellen, die Andreas vorhin erwähnt hat, die diese Information tragen, halt rauszufiltern. Sulfiridkerne sind einfach nur magnetische Ringe, die um Kabel gelebt werden. Wenn man zum Beispiel an ein Notebook Stromversorgungskabel hat, hat man kurz hinter dem Stecker immer so ein Gnubbel dran. Das ist ein Sulfiridkern, der genau diese hochfrequenten Strahlen rausfiltert.
Aber an den Notebook Netzteilen ist der wegen Tempest dran?
Das ist wegen der elektromagnetischen Verträglichkeit. Also genau der anderen Sache, dass keine anderen Geräte gestört werden. Und was man natürlich noch tun kann, ist explizit Störsender zu unterlegen. Auf den Frequenzen, wo man vermeintlich Strahlung absondert, die nicht draußen gehört werden soll, stellt man daneben einen Sender, der höhere Energie aussendet und damit praktisch die andere Strahlung überlagert.
Das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage gewesen. Ob das darf?
Nee, dürfen darf es natürlich nicht, aber machen kannst du es natürlich.
Es kommt auf die Energien, die man aussendet. Natürlich kann man das machen.
Na, wenn du so... Du musst ja Breitband nicht senden. Wir hatten es ja von Rechteckimpulsen und wie alle Leute, die ihre vier Semester Signalverarbeitung gemacht haben, wissen, hat so ein Rechteckimpuls eine unendlich große Bandbreite. Das heißt, der strahlt auf allen Frequenzen gleichzeitig.
Aber auch mit stark öffnender Energie in die oberen Frequenzen.
So schnell nimmt die nicht ab. Also durch die Tatsache, dass du ja einen Tiefpassfilter hast in der Leitung, dass es eine Grenzung gibt. Entschuldigung?
Hallo. Gut, also wir halten fest, es ist schwierig irgendwie mit Ferritkern.
Du musst irgendwie von 0 bis 500 Megahertz senden oder so und da muss man schon viel Energie reinstecken. Das mögen die bestimmt nicht so. Die lieben Kollegen von der RECTP, ist es immer noch die RECTP oder heißen die anders mittlerweile? Die heißen die die Frequenzaufsicht, die Bandwacht.
Also ich habe mal vor Bundesnetzagentur, danke lieber Chet. Vor ungefähr fünf Jahren mal einen Artikel in so einer CB-Funker Zeitschrift gelesen, die haben tatsächlich um Berlin rum so drei Messtürme aufgebaut und überwachen den gesamten Frequenzbereich über Berlin. Das heißt, wenn jemand mit ungewöhnlich starken Funksignalen in Berlin aufpoppt, können sie innerhalb von unter einer Sekunde irgendwie halt ihn triangulieren und orten. Und dann stehen sie halt innerhalb von kürzester Zeit bei dir vor die Tür.
Alles klar. Thomas, weißt du Bescheid? Keine Störsinn installieren. Könnte schnell gehen, dass du Besuch bekommst sonst. Thomas, weil du brav angerufen hast, bist du jetzt auch der, der entscheiden darf, ob wir jetzt noch Musik spielen vor den Nachrichten oder nicht?
Na, ich war der, der vorhin im Chat gesagt hat, ihr seid eine Talksendung und Musik läuft danach im Night Flight noch genug.
Was fragst du auch? Dann kann ich jetzt noch eine Gegenmaßnahme erzählen, die ich besonders lustig fand. Und zwar, wir hatten es ja vorhin von den Tiefpassfiltern. So Tiefpassfilter kann man auch in Software machen. Es gibt also einen Font, den man sich runterladen kann für seinen Computer, der speziell darauf designt wurde, dass möglichst wenig hochfrequente Energie dabei erzeugt wird. Das heißt, man kann sich die richtige Schriftart installieren, dann wird bei dem, der sich das Bild anguckt, das Bild matschig.
Also der Tempest sichere Zeichensatz.
Habt ihr das mal ausprobiert?
Nö, aber das hat Markus Kuhn gemacht, dem glaubt man das normalerweise.
Markus Kuhn ist also ein Name, bei dem man auch googeln kann, wenn man was über Tafeljagd aufhebt.
Der arbeitet am Institut von Russ Anderson in Cambridge. Also der weiß, was er tut.
Das hört sich gut an. Wir machen gleich weiter mit Tempest, vorher gibt es aber Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Jetzt ist die richtige Zeit, ein Instrument zu lernen, eine Band zu gründen und ein paar wirklich gute Songs aufzunehmen. Und wenn ihr das alles schon getan habt, umso besser. Denn er ist wieder da. Eine große Chance für kleine Bands. Legt euch jetzt ein Profil an auf meinfritz.de. Und mit ein bisschen guter Musik seid ihr dabei. Beim großen Finale am 18. September in Berlin. Die besten Bands landen sowieso im Fritz-Programm. Aber die Gewinner erhalten einen Scheck über 10.000 Euro für Musik-Equipment der Marken Kork, Vox und Lag.
Mehr Infos fritzee.
Der Radio-Award für neue Musik. Ihr habt die neue Musik, wir haben den Preis dazu.
Und das hört man um kurz vor halb zwölf.
Fritz-Info.
Nachrichten.
Mit Mario Bartsch.
Ein seit gestern Abend vermisstes Mädchen aus Eilenburg bei Leipzig ist tot aufgefunden worden. Die neunjährige Corinna sei vermutlich einem Gewaltverbrechen zum Opfer gefallenthalten, Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft mit. Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt könnten noch keine Aussagen zu den Todesumständen getroffen werden, da die gerichtsmedizinische Untersuchung noch bevorstehe. Suchkräfte hatten das Mädchen in einem Graben gefunden. Morgen wollen die Ermittler die Öffentlichkeit auf einer Pressekonferenz über den Fall informieren. Die deutsche Krebshilfe warnt davor, ins Solarium zu gehen. Hauptgeschäftsführer Nettighofen sagte der Neuen Osnabrücker Zeitung, er sei durch neue Forschungsergebnisse alarmiert. Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation hatte heute mitgeteilt, dass Sonnenbaden im Solarium genauso krebserregend ist wie Zigaretten und Aspässt. Besonders gefährdet sind Leute unter 30. Im organisierten Drogenhandel werden in Berlin immer öfter Minderjährige als Dealer eingesetzt. Einige Familien würden gezielt unter 14-Jährige losschicken, weil die noch nicht strafmündig sind. Hieß es vom Berliner Drogenhilfeprojekt Fixpunkt. Vor allem in den U-Bahnen der Bezirke Kreuzberg, Neukölln und Wedding werden die jungen Drogendealer eingesetzt. Am Montag hatte die Polizei in Kreuzberg einen 12 Jahre alten Jungen gefasst, der 150 Heroinkügelchen dabei hatte. Rekordweltmeister Michael Schumacher kehrt nach drei Jahren Pause in die Formel 1 zurück. Der 40-Jährige wird für den verunglückten Ferrari-Piloten Filipe Massa an den Start gehen, teilte der italienische Rennstall in Rom mit. Massa war am Sonnabend in der Qualifikation zum großen Preis von Ungarn verunglückt und liegt seitdem im Krankenhaus. Schumacher erklärte auf seiner Internetseite, er könne aus Verbundenheit zum Team diese unglückliche Situation nicht ignorieren und freue sich auf die Herausforderung. Das nächste Rennen findet am 23. August in Valencia statt. Heute Nacht wird es recht mild, es bleibt weiter trocken bei Tiefstemperaturen um 13 Grad. Am Tag gibt es dann weniger Sonne und es kann wieder einzelne Gewitter oder Schauer geben. Das Ganze bei maximal 27 Grad. A9 Berlin Richtung Halle Leipzig. Zwischen Belitz-Hallstetten und Belitz gibt es noch Behinderungen durch Bergerungsarbeiten, die ihre linke Spur ist blockiert. Atzen südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Zwischen Jenshagen und Rangsdorf gibt es Gefahr durch einen defekten Lkw, die rechte Spur ist blockiert. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin an 115 Awus, der Zubringe Nutetal statt einwärts. Im Dreieck Funkturm ist die Tangente in Richtung 100 gesperrt, sonst überall gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 89, 85, dann Fritz im Berliner Kabel.
Mit Markus Richter und Andreas im Starbuck von Chaos Computer Club, wo es heute darum geht, Geräte abzuhören und so, dass irgendwie jeder alles lesen kann, nur der kriegt nichts mit, der vor dem Gerät sitzt. Und in dieser Sendung wird auch Musik gespielt. Egal, ob ihr das wollt oder nicht. Reversing Gravity vom Bitmibs Syndicate. Das ist vom Game 3.0 Sampler und das ist, wie ihr euch denken könnt, Musik, die man einfach so und vor allem legal aus dem Netz ziehen kann. Weil so mit Netz geht es hier heute auch um Strom und überhaupt im Chaos Radio. Es geht um Tempest. Mag einer von euch vielleicht zu Anfang noch mal kurz erklären, was Tempest ist? Ich hab mir heute schon den Mund wurstelig geredet.
Äh, das ist, wenn der Computer aus Versehen funkt und deswegen der Nachbar weiß, welchen Porn man klickt.
Und du wolltest jetzt, es gibt zur Sendung auch ein Chat unter irc.freenode.net/chaosradio, also so ähnlich. Und du wolltest doch mal jemand schimpfen, der da im Chat unterwegs ist.
Ja, da wurden Bedenken angemeldet wegen des Rechtecksignals und des kontinuierlichen Spektrums. Und vielleicht formuliere ich es einfach noch mal präziser. Also so ein Rechtecksignal, das ist ja, also wenn man sich das anguckt, diese Flanke da, wenn die durch den Leiter fließt, das elektromagnetische Feld, das da erzeugt wird, ist ja die Ableitung davon. Und irgendwie so die Mathematiker leiten Rechtecke nicht ab. Die Physiker und Elektrotechniker tun das sehr wohl. Da kommt ein Dirak-Impuls raus. Also ist das Spektrum dessen, was bei diesem Rechtecksignal erzeugt wird, die Fourier-Transformation dieses Dirak-Impulses. Und das ist einfach über alle Frequenzen gleichmäßig verteilt.
Wie viele Semestersignalverarbeitungen muss man studiert haben, um das zu verstehen?
Das müsste man eigentlich spätestens nach dem zweiten Begriffen haben. Das ist schon relativ fundamental.
Ich habe zwei Semestersignalverarbeitungen durchlitten, möchte ich an dieser Stelle sagen. Und werde deshalb nicht weiter darauf eingehen, sondern lieber den Normen dran nehmen. Hi. Guten Abend.
Ich habe kein Wort verstanden von dem, was er gerade erzählt hat. Ich habe bestudiert von irgendwelchen Signalen. Ich habe nun einen Funkscanner benutzt.
Und was ist dann passiert?
Dann habe ich die Nachbarn gehört. Aber hier, das hat sich schon zehn Jahre her oder so was, da haben wir das Ding ausprobiert, ein Kaiser. Von Kaiser war das Teil. Und da sind tausend Kanäle und Schnick, Schnuck, Schnack da. Daran rumgestellt. Der hat sich die ja dann alleine gesucht. Und dann hast du irgendwann mal die Nachbarin gehört, komm mir morgen um elf oder ach, was ist das? Belanglose Scheiße halt. Gespandet, leider.
Ist das denn Tempest?
Es ist eigentlich kein Tempest, weil das ist ja sozusagen absichtliche Abstrahlung. Das sind ja Funkgeräte, die absichtlich den Inhalt des Gesprächs funken, so Babyfunken oder Schnurrlostelefone oder so. Also auch Abstrahlung, aber sozusagen beabsichtigte Abstrahlung.
Wir hören nämlich auch gerade deinen Nachbarn oder das Meer im Hintergrund oder was auch immer.
Ich bin auf der Autobahn, ich suche, hier kommt keine Alte Bucht. Ich hab die Rastigkeit an, wenn die ne kommt, aber hier ist leider keine.
Wenn jetzt ein Unfall hättest.
Da wollen wir lieber nicht live dabei sein. Hast du noch mehr mit deinem Funkscanner zu erzählen?
Ist ja eigentlich nicht das, was jeder bespricht. Daher, ich weiß nicht, so richtig passt das nicht.
Alles klar, dann würde ich an dieser Stelle sagen, eine gute Fahrt, Norman, weil wenn es nicht so richtig passt, dann glaube ich, passt das auch nicht so richtig.
Und weil telefonieren im Auto ist ja eh verboten.
Und beim Fahren auch noch und überhaupt.
Tempest und Telefone.
Warte mal, ich würde noch mal darauf zurückkommen wollen, weil ich glaube, es gibt immer noch Leute, die das nicht genau wissen, mit den Funktelefonen. Vielleicht könnte man an dieser Stelle noch mal ganz kurz erläutern, warum das kein Tempest ist, sondern quasi ganz normal, dass man Funktelefone heutzutage auch abhören kann.
Na also, es ist kein Tempest, weil der Sinn dieser Telefone ist, ihre Strahlung in die Gegend zu schicken. Und Tempest eigentlich genau besagt, dass man halt Signale auffängt, die halt nicht dazu gedacht sind, in die Umwelt abgestrahlt zu werden.
Jetzt ist aber schon so, dass ich denke, wenn ich telefoniere, auch wenn es mit einem kabellosen Telefon ist, dass ich nicht möchte, dass irgendjemand anders das hört.
Ja, ja, also das ist natürlich, es ist im Weitesten, es ist halt kein Tempest, aber es ist halt schon die gleiche Kategorie. Also es werden halt auch Funkwellen übertragen und man will halt nicht, dass es abgehört wird. Aber rein technisch ist es halt kein Tempest.
Ist kabelloses Telefon abhören schwieriger oder einfacher als Tempest?
Einfacher, weil die Energie natürlich viel höher ist. Weil die ja wirklich mit viel Energie raus blasen und gerade bei DECK zum Beispiel in den letzten paar Monaten oder zum Kongress letzten Jahres auch gezeigt wurde, dass die Verschlüsselung da nicht wirklich gut ist. Das heißt, man kann sich da eine PCMCA-Karte auf eBay klicken und eine Software installieren und kann halt DECK-Telefone mithören.
Und das für weniger als 1000 Euro.
Die Karten haben angefangen bei 5 Euro und dann kam die Software raus. Der höchste Preis war in dem Bereich von 200 Euro dann. Das ist man auch schon fast bei den 1000 Euro. Aber auf jeden Fall geht das theoretisch viel weniger Geld.
Du hattest jetzt noch eine Frage aus dem Chat, oder?
Genau, die Frage aus dem Chat war Tempest bei Geldautomaten.
Oh ja, das ist ein guter.
Möchte ich auch machen.
Das ist tatsächlich vorgekommen. Die haben relativ simpel gestrickte Tastaturen. Das Problem ist ja immer an die PIN anzukommen. Den Rest des Magnetstreffens kann man einigermaßen raten. Aber die PIN-Nummer nicht. Die Tastaturen an Geldautomaten machen natürlich auch Tempest-Abstrahlung. Es wurde tatsächlich in der Praxis eingesetzt, um an die PINs anzukommen. In Deutschland geht das nicht. Wenn man sich mal diese Eingabepads anguckt, die sind schon relativ durchdesigned. Die sind also aus dickem Stahl, das natürlich auch abschirmt, das auch nicht so einfach aufzumachen ist. Da ist auch mittlerweile ein Verschlüsselungskey drin. In anderen Ländern ist es halt nicht so, da sind die einfacher gestreckt.
Also ich würde sagen, also diese direkte elektromagnetische Abstrahlung geht da vielleicht nicht, aber halt dieses, was wir vorhin hatten, mit per Mikrofon die Tasten abhören, könnte man dadurch auch nochmal probieren.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Also ich muss mit Deutschland aber auf jeden Fall keine Sorgen machen.
Keine Sorgen musst du dir nie nirgendwo machen.
Okay, ich musste in Deutschland nicht übermäßig paranoid sein, was Geldautomaten angeht und Tempest.
Nee, du solltest paranoider sein, dass Vorschaltgeräte davor gebaut werden. Also dass jemand so was an den Magnetstreifen dran packt, wo man seine Karte reinschiebt, wo dann die Kamera dran ist.
Da gibt es eine coole Story. Sie haben, ich weiß nicht genau wo das war, Geldautomaten mit Pfefferspray ausgerüstet und die Pfefferspray gingen halt los, wenn sie halt ungewöhnliches Verhalten detektiert haben. Das hat natürlich die Techniker getroffen, die halt irgendwie an dem Automaten gerade rumgeschraubt haben. Also das muss man sich vorstellen. Sie haben wirklich mit der Kamera detektieren sie, ob da jemand irgendwie jetzt augenscheinlich versucht, was an den Automaten anzubringen. Und dann geht der Pfefferspray irgendwie los.
Automatisch.
Automatisch. Das hat halt wirklich drei Techniker verletzt.
Au.
Aber apropos Geschichten. Es wurden vorhin mehr lustige Geschichten gewünscht. Ich hab noch eine irgendwie, also wirklich finsterste Spooky 007 Geschichte. Vielleicht kriegen wir noch mal den Sound dazu. Die auch mit Tempest zu tun hat. Und ich fang einfach mal zu erzählen. Es gab damals eine Software in den 80ern, die hieß Promise. Die wurde geschrieben von einer amerikanischen Firma namens InSlaw. Die wurde dann in die Pleite getrieben. Die Software wurde aufgekauft von, möglicherweise war es die CIA, alles nicht ganz aufgeklärt. Ein gewisser Herr Maxwell ist durch die Gegend gereist und hat diese Software verkauft. Die diente dazu, Rasterfahndung zu machen. So kann man das am einfachsten erklären. Datenbanken aus verschiedenen Quellen zusammenzuführen, was heute auch getan werden soll mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Damals war das noch neu. Der Herr Maxwell ist rumgelaufen, hat diese Software verkauft an alle möglichen Leute, unter anderem den KGB und diverse andere Dienste. Irgendwann wurde Herr Maxwell vom Boot geschubst. Das ist aber nicht der Bestandteil der Geschichte, der spannend ist. Der spannende Teil ist, dass diese Software eine Hintertür hatte, wo Daten rausgekommen sind. Bekannter war es. Es gibt jetzt einige Spekulationen darüber. Hier schreibt gerade jemand, er glaubt, dass es der Mossad war. Das glauben alle anderen auch. Zumindest war es der Mossad, der vom Boot geschubst hat.
Andere Geschichte.
Andere Geschichte. Reden wir nicht drüber, sondern Tempest. Jetzt war es ja früher so, dass die Rechner nicht unbedingt alle am Internet hingen. Das heißt, wenn man da eine Software drauf gekriegt hat, mit Hintertür drin, also sagen wir mal, man hat an den KGB Promis verkauft und möchte an die Daten, muss man die da irgendwie rauskriegen. Und es ist bekannt, dass die Daten per Funk rausgekommen sind. Und jetzt spekulieren noch alle rum. Es gibt Leute, die meinen, dass da gezielt Rechner verkauft wurden mit einer Wanze drin. Aber die viel plausiblere Erklärung ist, dass da Tempest eingesetzt wurde. Also die Software gezielt bestimmte Zugriffe auf die Busse erzeugt hat, die dazu geführt haben, dass die Rechner abgestrahlt haben, dass über große Entfernung abhörbar war. Also ähnlich wie wir das hatten mit dem Radio und der Musik zu dem Spiel in den 70ern, nur dass dann die Daten rausgefallen sind.
So einen will ich auch zu Hause. Und dann will ich ihm irgendjemand geben, einem Chef zum Beispiel. Wir sind jetzt fast am Ende der Sendung. Ich würde gerne noch ein bisschen mit euch in die Zukunft gucken, weil es hat sich im Verlauf dieser Sendung jetzt so herausgestellt. Okay, Tempest geht. Es ist theoretisch auch ein Problem, was Leute betrifft, die mit wichtigen Dingen zu tun haben. Aber spielt im Alltäglichen jetzt nicht wirklich eine Rolle. Wie wird das in zehn Jahren aussehen? Wird Tempest dann wieder wichtiger, weil alle Leute irgendwie ihr Zeug verschlüsseln? Oder bleibt das eher so eine Art theoretische Überlegung, wo man denkt, naja gut, es funktioniert, aber letztendlich ist es einfacher irgendwie mitzusniffen?
Na, dass das Problem an Tempest ist, dass man halt in der Regel relativ nah ran muss. Also für beliebige Definitionen von nah, aber irgendwie auf jeden Fall muss man sich aus dem Haus bewegen und halt irgendwo hingehen. Und das natürlich immer schon ein gewisser Aufwand. Das heißt, so lange man keine Drohnen hat, die automatisch vor die Fenster fliegen und irgendwie dort die Kamera, das Mikrofon oder was auch immer platzieren, wird Tempest halt immer mit einem gewissen Aufwand verbunden sein. Deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass es sich jetzt für die Sachen durchsetzen wird, sondern da gibt es halt einfach andere Möglichkeiten, die halt einfacher sind.
Aber ist es nicht sozusagen, weil es gerade so ein Ding ist, wo niemand mit rechnet? Ich habe immer dieses Beispiel von der kleinen Rechtsanwaltskanzlei, die einen wichtigen Fall bearbeitet. Da rechnet jetzt niemand damit, dass nebenan jemand sitzt, der sich so eine Technik anstatt schafft.
Also wie gesagt, Kosten und Nutzen. Also ich meine, wenn es halt wirklich ein Lohn des Ziels ist, wird es halt sicherlich auch Leute geben, die Tempest benutzen. Aber das ist halt irgendwie jetzt so, das wird in zehn Jahren so sein. Also ich sehe da nicht, dass es sich großartig da verändern wird.
Würde sich das Problem irgendwann erledigen, weil die elektromagnetische Abstrahlung so klein wird, dass sie dann nicht mehr messbar ist?
Das würde ich sagen auch nicht. Also alles, was man nicht irgendwie im Computer verarbeiten kann, kann man halt auch irgendwie mit anderen Devices wieder messen. Also genauso wie bei Chips, wenn man die halt herstellen kann, kann man sie irgendwie auch reverse-ingenieren. Das heißt, es gibt halt immer eine Technik, um halt die Technik, die benutzt wird, irgendwie abzuhören. Und deswegen, also es wird wahrscheinlich schwieriger werden, mit einem Scwambling oder irgendwie Falschsignale einstreuen, was auch immer, aber unmöglich wird es halt irgendwie nie sein.
Und meinst du, das wird in Zukunft mit den Geräten eingebaut, dass sie quasi gleich das Tempest Anti-Tool mitbringen?
Na, was zum Beispiel die neuen DVI-Monitore machen, die machen halt wirklich Verschlüsselung über das Monitorkabel. Das heißt, du hast halt einen Chip in dem Monitor drin, du hast einen Chip oder den Key in der Grafikkarte und übermittelst die Daten jetzt nur noch gekryptet über die Antenne.
Das heißt, es wird erst innerhalb vom Monitor entschlüsselt. Aber kann man da noch die Abstrahlung von dem Bild messen, oder ist es dann zu sagen, wenn es durchs Kabel ist, ist es gut?
Die bleibt natürlich, ja.
Was es auch gibt, ist ein Ansatz, der bei Chipkarten gemacht wird. Also es gibt ja das Problem, dass Leute Schlüssel aus Chipkarten auslesen wollen, zum Beispiel damit sie umsonst Premiere gucken können. Das heißt ja nicht mehr Premiere. Aber zum Beispiel. Und dass diese Seitenkanalangegriffe, die ja mit Tempest verwandt sind, darauf angewendet werden. Da werden interessante Dinge gemacht. Da wird dann also das Programm so geschrieben, dass es immer gleich schnell abläuft, egal welche Daten verarbeitet werden. Oder es werden intern die Daten so repräsentiert, dass man sozusagen jede Null und jede Eins einmal als Null und einmal als Eins hat. Also sagen wir mal, man hat...
Es hört sich alles gleich an quasi.
Es hört sich alles gleich an. Man hat eine Null im Register, wird bei einem normalen Computer überall der Strom rausgenommen. Und bei dem Computer hat man dann für jedes Bit zwei Zellen, wo immer eine Eins ist und eine Null. Je nachdem welche Eins und Null ist, wird entschieden, ob es insgesamt eine einzelne Null ist. Anstatt dass viel Strom reinfließt und da kein Strom rausfließt.
Ich glaube zu dem Thema sollte man mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Also das ist auf jeden Fall relativ interessant. Nein, über Chipkarten.
Chipkarten, das ist ein guter Plan. Das ist ja Chipkarten-Hacking, weil das ist ein echt spannendes Thema.
Da muss man halt vor allem irgendwie auch mal weiter ausholen, um das dann irgendwie alles ein bisschen näher zu machen.
Okay, das machen wir dann vielleicht in einer der zukünftigen Sendungen. Jetzt ging es irgendwie... Tempest ist eine von den Seitenkanalattacken. Ich hatte dir heute schon erzählt, irgendwie es gibt auch, dass man die Tastatur einfach anhört. Also mit dem Mikrofon. Oder wir hatten auch schon den Chip, den man zum Beispiel...
Ich hab noch eins, das sie nicht hatten. Und zwar Optischabstrahlung. Also das Beispiel ist irgendwie... Licht ist ja natürlich auch eine elektromagnetische Welle. Und das Beispiel, was ich gefunden hab, ist, dass früher, so vor zehn Jahren ungefähr, Switches und Hubs halt diese Blink-LEDs hatten, die angezeigt haben, ob da jetzt Link drauf ist und ob da Daten überflackern. Und was sie halt getan haben, ist halt auf den... Also sie haben halt aus Versehen auf die LEDs halt die Daten rauf moduliert. Das heißt, sie haben halt einfach mit einer Kamera oder mit einem CCD-Sensor halt oben auf die LEDs sich raufgesetzt und konnten daraus die Daten rekonstruieren, die halt gerade über diesen Switch-Sport gelaufen sind.
Oder ein anderes schönes Beispiel, wenn man nachts an Fenstern vorbei läuft, dann schimmert das manchmal so blau, wenn die Leute Fernsehen gucken. Das ist in der Tat so schnell, wenn man da ausreichend schnell hinguckt mit der passenden Elektronik, kann man auch wieder den Bildschirminhalt rekonstruieren.
Okay.
Noch eins? Gehirntempest. Also um mal zu sagen, wirklich in die Zukunft zu schweifen. Also ich mein, im Gehirn sind auch nur elektromagnetische oder sagen wir elektrische Impulse, die da irgendwie rumfliegen. Und die kann man natürlich irgendwie heutzutage auch schon relativ gut von außen, naja relativ gut von außen sichtbar machen. Also hier kriegt man diese Kappe auf.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, man muss schon relativ dicht ran, oder?
Da muss man schon relativ dicht ran. Aber das ist halt auch alles nur eine Frage von Signal und Rauschen dahinter. Das heißt, mit guter Technik kriegt man das wahrscheinlich in später auch von ein bisschen weiter weg. Und ich meine, wenn man halt nicht dicht dran kommt, dann gibt es halt irgendwie auch die Möglichkeit, zum Beispiel in später wird es ja auch mal Implantate geben, die halt direkt mit dem Gehirn interagieren oder halt irgendwie dein Auge als Implantat haben. Und da kann man natürlich dann auch wieder ganz andere Fragen, der Tempest-Sicherheit bzw. der Abstrahlung dieser Geräte irgendwie auf.
Ist das eigentlich heutzutage schon so, es gibt ja irgendwie so schon Herzschrittmacher und irgendwie sowas, dass man da Dinge tun kann oder lesen kann?
Kann man, aber da halt irgendwie, also die haben halt auch so ein über Funk zum Beispiel ein Interface, um das, um den Herzschrittmacher zu steuern bzw. zu programmieren. Also das ist halt wieder die gewollte Schnittstelle.
Die auch nicht besonders sicher ist.
Die auch leider nicht besonders sicher ist, ja. Ne, zu viel Paranoia.
Also wenn du einen Herzschrittmacher trägst, hol dir eine abgeschirmte Jacke.
Vielleicht auch ein Thema für eine andere Sendung. Apropos andere Sendung, wusstest du schon, was ihr nächstes Mal macht?
Ne, das wissen wir erst zwei Tage vorher.
Oh, das ist ja eine Überraschung.
Wollen wir nicht Chipkarten machen? Du kannst dich jetzt freiwillig bereiterklären.
Das ist zwei Wochen nach der HA. Also sollten wir auf jeden Fall demnächst mal machen.
Wir tun jetzt mal Chipkarten auf die Liste, wir tun Medizingeräte auf die Liste. Wenn ihr, liebe Hörer, einen Vorschlag habt, worüber wir reden sollten, worüber wir immer schon mal zwei Stunden lang quasseln sollten, dann schickt uns den. Wir machen das gerne.
Gibt es einen Jingle für die Mail-Andresse?
Ne, ich weiß die auch gar nicht, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Na, chaosradio.ccc.de Ah, ich hätte jetzt gedacht info.chaosradio.de Das geht bestimmt auch.
Aber jetzt hier nicht die Leute verunsichern.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Es gibt doch bestimmt auch ein Wiki und was auch immer. Aber ansonsten irgendwie die Kommunikation.
Also chaosradio.de ist auf jeden Fall die Seite, wo ihr alles findet, was man über diese Sendung zu wissen hat. Zum Beispiel auch den Podcast der Sendung, den gibt's da bald, nehme ich mal an. Und wenn ihr wollt, hören wir uns im... Ne, wir nicht. Aber das Chaosradio hört ihr wieder in einem Monat.
Einen haben wir noch.
Einen haben wir noch?
Genau. Und zwar der 29. Juli. Heute jetzig der 8. Togolstag von Vau Holland, der Gründer des CCC, einer der Mitbegründer und unser quasi philosophischer Vater. Und an den möchten wir hier noch mal erinnern.
Also die letzten fünf Minuten, also eine Minute Schweigeminute und dann noch mal eine Musik.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das Problem ist, dass wir hier eine Technik haben, die in den 20 Sekunden nix sagen, geht irgendwie das Notprogramm los. Und ich glaube, das ist eine Welle, die man äh, äh, egal. Ich würde sagen, wir widmen einfach den nächsten Song.
Du meinst ungeeignet für eine Schweigeminute.
Ja, das, um es diplomatisch auszudrücken, so rum. Ich empfehle an dieser Stelle die nachfolgende Sendung. Maxwell, der gerade hier im Chaosradio vom Boot gestoßen wurde, macht jetzt demnächst den Night Flight. Und die folgende Musik widmen wir dann Vau Holland. Ich weiß nicht, darf man das einfach so? Darf man einfach so mal Musik widmen? Professor Click ist es nämlich. Er hat diesen Song extra geschrieben, um an Vau Holland zu denken.
Ciao.
Lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.
Und immer schön panierig bleiben.
Danke für's Zuschauen.